the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
the players were rested and recharged
following the rest day at the super bet
chess classic in bucharest romania with
only a few rounds remaining players
battled to move up in the standings in
hopes of gaining crucial grand chess
tour points champions win with black and
so does lavonne aronian winning his
second game of the event with the black
pieces and tying for the lead with
fellow american wesley so
day seven of spectacular chess coming up
next
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day seven of
the superbad chess classic the first
stop of the 2022 grand chess tour held
here in beautiful bucharest romania we
start the day in front of the obelisk a
monument dedicated to the fallen
soldiers of the 1989 revolution well we
have a lot of soldiers battling out on
the chessboard let's go to the studio
and start the day with yasser peter
beautiful footage of the romanian
capital as we welcome you to our
coverage of round seven of the superbad
chess classic the first stop
of the 2022 grand chess tour
hi i'm peter svidler and happy to be
here with the assassin as per usual as
am i peter as always hello everyone and
welcome to our live coverage as we get
ready to begin round seven there's been
some serious jocking for position at the
top peter so take us through our
standings
mainly people are joking for position to
catch up to wesley so and it finally
happened the one iranian won a game
yesterday
and is now tied for
first with wesley and look at that
chasing pack of wolves that's only one
point yeah a remarkable tie from third
to seventh there on on 50
and three people in the minus including
two of our candidates and uh chakra are
in that last not really having a very
good tournament so far no not really and
our format peter uh this is a ten player
round robin with uh the standard feeder
time control so it is so called 90
minutes for the first 40 moves then 30
minutes for the rest of the game with
the increment of half a minute starting
from one
no draw offers at all and a standard
scoring system in place with one point
for a win or half a point for a draw
with six rounds under our belt what is
our remaining schedule
yeah we've only got three rounds left
one today one tomorrow on friday the
13th by the way yes and there is also uh
last round of course and possibly the
playoffs on saturday if required
and alejandro you're in studio to tell
us how the players got here and their
road ahead nice to see you my friend
good morning st louis a pleasure to be
with both of you and of course you
mentioned that two players have
separated themselves from the pack it's
only a point but it is a significant
lead let's see how they got their
starting with levon out on and he's had
a real roller coaster off a tournament
he started with a weird but very
interesting game against richard rapport
then he drew a better position against
bogdan dayak he was completely lost
against furuja but somehow managed to
save that game and then played a great
game against linear dominguez the next
day to win with the black pieces drew a
nothing game against wesley swann then
took advantage of mvl's opening mistakes
to win again with black and now he finds
himself in a tie for first place with
wesley let's take a look at his coming
up matches he'll be white against
fabiano carolina today he'll be black
against janae pomnyacci tomorrow and
he'll finish against a lockless shack
mamadiarov in the ninth round certainly
a lot of points to be made for levon if
he wants to press with white meanwhile
wesley has had a completely different
tournament even though they both have
the same amount of points it looks
completely from a different world it's
been a very solid affair taking
advantage of the mistakes that his
opponents have made he was able to put
his opponents under pressure and let
them crack that's how he won against
shaq and that's how he won against nepo
meanwhile the other games he had some
pressure against caruana in round three
but was unable to do anything with the
extra pawn and that game ended in a draw
let's take a look at his road ahead he
will be playing with the black pieces
against the local hero book and they act
today he'll be having a great fight
tomorrow as he's white against alareza
for ruja and he will be finishing with
the black pieces against his countrymen
lay near dominguez certainly still a
tough road ahead for both of the leaders
and as you mentioned only one point
separating them from a hungry pack of
wolves well let's take a look at our key
matchups today with our friends in
bucharest anastasia and christian
thank you alejandro and welcome back
everybody to day seven of the 2022 super
bad chess classic from location here in
bucharest romania to call all the action
and give you guys live updates i am your
host grand master christian carrillo
alongside my brilliant co-host one
grandmaster anastasia karlovic anastasia
welcome back to the studio yesterday we
had a fun but very long day the games
ended after five and a half hours what
are you looking forward to today also
what have you been doing today uh before
the round started yeah hello everyone
hello christian always nice to be here
with you in the studio and also it's
great to weather in bucharest we have
another sunny day and i've been walking
around and actually met
levon aronyam just now he was in the
elevator he also had good time walking
around
listening to music and now here we are
back to the playing hall and expecting
really interesting fights today right
speaking about the fights what games do
you have your eyes set on for today's
round yeah it's really difficult to
choose one but
i decided to keep my eyes on the game
between um
richard robert and and well because i
remember their big fight which happened
during the grand prix event this
dramatic match which ended up with
victory of richard robert and then well
literally is looking forward to for
revenge i guess in this game uh it's
really interesting that richie managed
to defeat um well with white pieces and
credited his wife uh with who found
really great idea in broomfield which
doesn't happen that often right against
a well so i'm looking forward to see
what will
family uh prepared today absolutely
that's going to be definitely a barn
burner of a matchup about one game that
i'm definitely having my eyes on since
the beginning of the tournament actually
anastasia is the big all-american clash
between levon aronian with the white
pieces against fabiano caruana well
these players know each other very well
they've played so many times but we see
a bit of a discrepancy in wins versus
lawsuits levon aronian with nine wins
but 13 losses and actually one of those
losses came a couple of weeks ago in the
american cup the last time these two
players faced each other in a mini match
while levon actually had to win too many
matches to win the american cup he was
unable to win even the first mini match
put a lot of pressure in fact with the
black pieces in their first game but
after that he succumbed under the
tremendous pressure of fabiano caruana
well today i have a feeling he is out
for blood he is out for revenge and
we're going to have an amazing game guys
what fights do you have your eyes on
well thank you christian and thank you
anastasia family business i like that
very very much let's take a look at all
the pairings peter
lay the table for us please certainly uh
jan is playing the white pieces today
against shakhtar and mizera for a game
where
i think uh considering how poor of a
tournament chocolatier is living young
would be very interested in perhaps
getting getting a bite out of the
opening and and pressing on uh yeah
iranian carolina is just a fantastic
match i was i was shocked at how high
the decisive percentage 22 to 25 almost
a 50 percent
close to
considering how strong they are and how
well they're equipped in the openings
this is a staggering percentage
rapport versus mvl is a very interesting
one picked by anastasia and the
interesting stuff there is it's one
versus one uh three in mvl's favor right
but that victory coming in perhaps the
most important game played between them
yeah so far so richie is sort of in the
ascendancy there winning that game in
the semis of the uh the grand prix uh
finally lost the game yesterday so his
tournament lost some of its last term
but still having a very very solid uh
event white against wesley and theresa
furujo on the white side of the game
against the year dominguez
he really wants to win a game it's clear
that he is
really i mean he's been pretty much
going all in with black by this point
yeah exactly dislikes being on -1
intensely as you can you can see but so
far unable to unable to break through
everybody's fighting hard and what are
they fighting for peter
the prize fund in this tournament is a
there's a very rich burst
here as you can see there's a hundred
grand up top for first and the gct
points
in the right column they will count
towards the tourist endings and if you
win the tournament outright without
tigers you get 13 points and we a win on
tiebreak gets you 12 and very nice prize
money all the way down to 10.5
350 000 in total price fund as we get
ready for our ceremonial opening first
move and i understand something
different for today
uh we're we're not entirely sure how
this will happen but we have a bunch of
people making first moves hopefully not
the not on the same board and some some
very uh illustrious people uh will be
doing it but we'll wait until
uh i think you're right
things start happening to
update you on this all right
it seems like our first victim
yeah and this is this is adrian muto uh
he who is uh now armenian soccer manager
which i think is not doing not doing him
justice he was a very prominent player
in his time played for chelsea played
for uh
italian clubs of uh
ooh e2e3 very defensive yeah kind of
like a cagey a cage little move there
but
trying to trap play for you
in a very illustrious playing career but
is now uh
managing
and we we also have a couple of other
people potentially going on stage to to
make ceremonial moves but we'll wait
until that
that happens to three victims in total
are expected
we continue
being very pleasantly
impressed by the
yeah and this is the uh ceo of first
first bank remaining
that sounds very dutch yeah that is me i
mean uh the bank of romania yeah ceo
the first the first part of that name
means horse i don't know about the
second point
after leaf
knight f3 yeah and uh
it does choose the horse i see
and sneaking on stage as the ceremonial
gas departs
that was pretty ah look at the sporting
isn't it
this has a little live on going melee
and and this is andre diaconesco uh ceo
for one united properties
uh
making a very aggressive first move as
well evil much much more aggressive than
the previous
e2 e3
that was nice i like that and what you
were about to say is that we are getting
a very impressive number of celebrities
and sports people uh from romania to
join the tournament that's very nice
shout out to the organizers absolutely
and you know for me for me the the
filter there so to speak is like i
really have stopped following sports
ball of any kind apart from cricket at
some point but even i know who andrea
mutu is
very good and for you have you ever been
i mean you've had a lot of ceremonial
first moves being made on your boards
who really uh
with some of the outside the standout
yeah if you don't mind i'm not entirely
sure it's it's difficult to
you get you get sports people you get
culture people you get all kinds of very
interesting uh interesting uh first
movers first movers there you go but
recently bias like
i i have to go there with you know
adrian motor has to be very much up
there he is a very prominent alejandro
jump right in uh who who uh first movers
uh
kind of uh knocked you backwards
i think i surprised a niche actually
because i was the first mover in a
tournament in china
he was very surprised to see me the
organizers told me they want to make the
first move i did anish was shocked
i remember in an olympiad in
manila
the president of the country corazino
aquino came and made the first move on
gary kasparov's table
and gary was black and he shook her hand
and said very nice she said play
[Laughter]
so gary made d5 she she played c4 so
play
oh gary was like what
e6 she played knights e3
and gary said would you like a draw
and then her spokesman said very
reluctantly the president of the country
accepts a draw from the world champion
gary cosborough come to think of it i
think we've had like woody harrelson
make the first move yeah championship
match in 2018 i think
yeah so there has been some very
prominent names
roped into it right
uh
the bishop's opening no petrov for you
today
no the last time we had a classical
chaste tournament with two bishops
opening right in the same event
it's because the petrov has been causing
i think i think uh
we it could have been maybe it could
have snuck in uh
slightly because
it does transpose into italians quite a
bit and then you kind of
you kind of forget it started as a
bishop opening c7 c6 though i mean the
way of meeting the bishops right the
trans positions but like if you go 96
here f4 i'm not sure it's such a great
no sorry i think generally yeah i mean
people do play knight c3 but knight f3
just immediately takes it back into
classical italians and then you remember
it as an italian
uh but yeah
pure pure bishop openings maybe not not
very often
maybe not very often at all
i just never by accident
looks like an
equipment malfunction what do we got
going on there
[Laughter]
the arbiters say look i know you're not
going to use these minutes anyway so
let's just take it away from you you
don't need them
stop pretending
exactly
and away you go i just accidentally
happen to have at the game between yon
and shaq
open on my board and it almost looks
like a bishop's opening it's not exactly
it's opening it is a joke of a piano we
would have we wouldn't
like we would need to go back to move
two and check which move order yeah just
to make sure that it was in a bit of
something
no it wasn't and uh the joker piano and
that's certainly d5
yeah this is uh
somewhat uh
worrying for me but uh
recently i think this line has become a
lot more
uh combative and it's
at some point i felt that all of these
lines where black tries to play the 75
in one tempo as early as possible
normally by move six if
you know if nothing is stopping it they
have been at some point at least to maya
has analyzed almost to a draw it's
remarkable uh it really is because of
how concrete this is and right how
strategically justified this is that
white needs to do something very forcing
in reply to try and uh you know force
the forced issue before black completely
finishes development and those lines
seem to me like they were analyzed
almost into dust
but there have been some developments
recently which i think lead to positions
which are still very concrete but are
geared more towards just a kind of a
sharp and clear fight in which yes black
i still think is completely fine but
it's less of a force draw and more of a
kind of a fighting equality
uh which is something i would like i
would like to see today because we we
obviously don't particularly want these
players to just blitz out 25 moves of
known theory
exactly
for me uh the move d75
is really
the absolute challenge if you don't get
anything against d7 d5 then this line is
perfectly uh playable for for black and
that's it i mean no advantage from the
opening it is definitely the way to you
know at least attempt solving uh
all of your problems in the joker piano
without having to deal with like 25
different little move orders when you
play something slower like if you go for
g6 a6 exactly as we were taught to do
when we were like i'm not sure what your
your attitude was when you were yeah no
no no i mean it was even perfunctory d6
was on the board maybe yeah
yeah yeah the feeling was you have
already equalized and there will be no
and then no problems whatsoever like the
entire opening was failed to be a
cop-out right uh i played i played the
uh the spanish exclusively as uh as a
youngster and when people played the
italian against me i i felt like i have
already sort of won the opening battle
because they're declining to discuss you
know the serious openings the actual
openings you know and yeah these days
it's very very different and this is one
of the most topical positions of the
entire line you can take on g3 white
takes only five black plays queen of
five the end game of the bishop d193 is
not supposed to be entirely equal even
though it is symmetrical and shouldn't
be all that bad but people kind of avoid
it because it's not really
the engine doesn't give you full
equality there and alejandro i have the
impression we saw this maybe the
american cup it was very recent
i think we saw i'm trying to recall
which game but uh yeah in this game let
me put it pull it up
here uh yeah we saw the move a5 i want
to say in the american cup before they
took on d3 i believe it was
i want to say it was dominguez shankland
but maybe it was trunk line dominguez
because they both played this variation
i think it was a5 a4 and then they took
on d3 right and we went down a long
variation it's not appearing on my board
so i must have something mixed up i
think if you want to include a5 and a4
it's probably not right here it's not
with the pawn on h3 maybe
because here yeah a5 you go g4 right g4
and also even knight f4 knight g3 seems
to me to be very promising although they
play bishop d6 these days yeah and they
don't really i know that in the american
cup we saw a5 a4 in the sink field cup
here we saw king a cheat between maxima
shirley graf and dario
yeah that's a great game uh queen takes
d3 is still the main line in this
position and i don't think we have a
move yet so shocks are deciding which
one of the of the three and uh a very
interesting kind of a quirky little uh
accident here in terms of uh occurrence
of the same openings we have two qgas
today
oh really
i've got one on yeah the face the face
alejandro is making i i very much relate
to but at least in one of them white
hasn't played b3 so maybe we will get
we will get one of them
in position uh daniel uh bogdan has just
played the move b2b3 a move that i
really
ascribed to um rubenstein in cuba
rubinstein his idea was very
straightforward he wanted to play bishop
b2 put his knight on d2 and this knight
comes to e5 this bishop often drops back
to f3 and it was a
a very simple line of uh just trying to
use your extra development extra tempo
here are their takes on d4 everybody
should be taking with the knight yes and
that came very quickly
but one of the problems is wesley when
he's playing the queen's gambit accepted
it just feels like him and magnus and
most especially somehow the white
players just leave the opening with
nothing like yeah and nothing and also
specifically playing b3 against wesley
uh
it's it's uh
his own bat line he played it in this
tournament against mvl on the white side
so you're not going to be uh surprising
very much with the with the ideas and
the motifs
of this line if you play b3 but as i
said uh you know bogdan uh had a bit of
a setback in the previous round and uh
if he wants to play safer
it is very understandable and actually
in his earlier uh foray into into this
opening he played this line against
levon
early in the tournament they had a very
sharp position by move 20 where i mean
it ended up being a kind of a dry or dry
end game which levon came close to
winning right but in the middle game uh
they had a very sharp position which
could have exploded into sacrificial
lines and uh would have been very very
interesting so the alejandro what was
the other uh queen's gambit accepted
that we're seeing
okay uh more excitement than this one
it's it's sad news for grunfeld players
it's that news for player because this
is the second time mvl said
i don't want to play anti-grunfeld's i
don't want to go into that let's go
instead into
this positions with d takes c4 queen's
gambit accepted on both boards who is
this it's mvl but in this position we
have an early bishop b3 without castling
i don't really know what the point of
this is after c5 i assume that you have
to castle in this place i think the
point is you win three minutes on the
clock three minutes on the clock you win
great but i have to say as the chess fan
as a chess commentator i'm about as
excited
that the queen's gambit accepted is
making a resurgence as i am for somebody
telling me that the berlin is back in
action baby no i mean the queen ga it's
a great opening it's very solid for
black but it does lead to a lot of drive
positions there will be some exciting
ones and there will be some lines like
the ones we see today between dak and so
that yes one side may be pushing for a
little bit but it's going to be
you know a slow
not super exciting fight
boy i feel really sad for your chessable
sales i mean if if mvl is not going to
play the grunfeld who's going to buy the
course
come on they're giving up on the
groomfeld isn't that just a little bit
harsh peter
this is uh you know obviously
the tragedy of our times exactly exactly
armageddon i i feel okay so we were
seeing two queens gambit accepted and by
the way in an interesting trip yes
please
king h8 oh yeah king shade uh has been
played in 94 97 this is i think still
following that game between mvl and
darius right
and there have been i think more games
in that line since there was a
reasonably at least one high-profile
game which followed that the same
the same line the the the game between
mvl and darish and vale ended up winning
but it was
very very decent for black at one point
at least
again if you want to play queen takes d3
that is the main line the king h8 as uh
alejandra explained
is a definite alternative yeah this is
uh still following a game between uh
newpom niche and ironian as well so
that was our stem game when we were
preparing for the nvl game
knight e4 with the tempo against the
bishop
surprise the bishop does not move it
just gets defended with the move knight
d7 and i think we've caught up to the
player
uh thus far
again a very developing
swiftly in this uh line alejandro oh
absolutely uh there's this is a
variation that everybody's looked at i
believe in the past year and a half i've
looked at it for three different
students this variation is involved in
both king h8 and queen takes d3
whether it's the sinful cup the world
cup something or another i've ended up
looking at this line quite heavily and
it seems to never end it's one of those
variations that just keeps on going
keeps on going there's always ideas and
even the variations they never reach
some kind of forced conclusion like some
perpetual or something like that drawn
end game it just kind of keeps going and
it keeps the game interesting so it's
still relatively unexplored only four
games from this position okay but people
have been looking at it quite heavily
now white's won all the games so far
all of the games all of the games but
you know with only four games not
exactly well still i mean it kind of
speaks for itself right four out of four
what's what's black been doing wrong
i believe that the positions that you
get at the end sometimes require some
precision and sometimes it's just luck
of the draw right
okay
may i be the first to ask can i take the
pawn
g2 g4 i chase the bishop
i took us
but the three will be hanging what point
well just a second just a second i've
got an idea
i want you to take on d3 with the knight
even that
might be playable but probably not yeah
i was intending to yeah i understand i'm
trying to find a way maybe to sacrifice
something here but it won't work no but
i mean you want to take a b three three
three
that shouldn't be very much yeah and we
signed the score sheets
i'm actually slightly worse here i'm
actually i would like to look for
something better because here it takes
takes rookie seven it might be a bit
annoying all right yeah it's about to
say
yes it might be a little bit annoying
slightly better i mean wesley would uh
what wesley would work hard to bring
home before
yeah i want to take on d3 with the
bishop immediately i think is a much
cleaner solution without keeping the
queens on for the time being like maybe
that looks yeah because you you did play
g2 g4 so i think i'm incentivized to
remind you of that by keeping the queens
on and good point very good point
i don't expect too many even here i'm
probably preferring white after queen of
three i think we have three
three
creating a threat of rugby g5 hitting b7
i'm probably still picking white but i'm
not expecting very much if i if i have
this position in the game i'm not
expecting her how did white win four
games than alejandro it wasn't uh
connected to g2
bishop d5 is the main move here that's
the main yeah
there was a really weird game in the
grand swiss where
uh i believe uh sasha kiran here against
ferruja played a five knight
h6 and white just took that exchange and
won very convincingly which
like five knight eg5 h6 i believe this
yeah took that exchange
and he just went 969 takes a fight and
won shockingly yeah
that was i was there for the grand swiss
and i was i was watching that live and
thinking something not not quite
understandable to to me is happening
here
the russian school of champions
it looks like white has more rooks and
you know i may be wrong but it does
appear to me that white has
an abundance of rooks and rooks being
more valuable than minor pieces yeah you
were a little confused i was a little
bit confused yeah exactly
so bishop d5 f5 looks like an overreach
uh but great you've played bishop d5
what's the idea bishop b6 i think is
what they play here and if knight g3
as often is the case in these types of
positions the idea actually is to take
on f3 and mid queen takes f3 with f5
okay this is why you play king h8
basically to have access to the move f7
and f5 in all of these types of
positions things are heating up yeah and
this is actually following the the very
stem stem game here is the nippon
sheranian gaming which i think
young played d3 g4
d3 d4 yeah
trying to break open the uh the pair in
the center and i think levon replied
with f4 94 and e takes d4
and that didn't quite work out but i
remember i looked at this i think after
the game i think queen h4 in this
position is pretty decent if i remember
correctly
uh
white is pretty much never worse but
black is is fine if if they know where
they're knowing
wow okay and the lifetime between uh
these two we have three wins two losses
five draws also what kind of a
shockingly low number of gigs yeah yeah
like i don't quite understand how they
only played ten how many ten games yeah
and actually yeah i understood some
years off right
jan just took some years off that is
true he didn't play that many
tournaments he played but he didn't play
like five that plays pretty much every
super tournament that's out there i
think there was a period of what two
three years where nepal was interested
in other ventures in life
right yeah and i i before we go too deep
down uh theories like rabbit holes in
italians i want to point out that there
is something very exciting to my eyes at
least happening in the game we haven't
even put on the board yet the game
between alireza and
lanier and alejandro you have it on your
board tell us what attracted you to it a
little bit of chess fashion here coming
into play because this variations of the
nimzo indian are making a strong showing
here at this point i think
for many years it didn't really matter
if you played c5 or d5 white was going
to develop his knight usually to f3 and
then you put the other pawn in the
center c5 knight of three d5 d5 knight
f3 c5 it didn't really matter but lately
it does matter it feels like you get
into completely different scenarios
whether you play one pawn or the other
and the thing is after d5 white has been
snapping that pawn as quickly as
possible
something that you cannot do on c5 and
the difference is this move a3 bishop d6
and queen c2 and they try to develop
with this knight g on e2 trying to play
this more or less like they play a
queen's gambit decline orthodox
variation but with the knight on e2
instead of f3 and you say the bishop is
not out that's true but in the
variations of f3 e4 sometimes the bishop
can make its way to f2 anyway and with
the same amount of tempe sometimes the
bishop is fine on c1 with the knight on
f3 you could argue that the bishop on c1
yeah it doesn't have as much use but
with the knight on e2 perhaps there will
be a use for it later and we do see this
kind of plans uh play out here c6 knight
g2 rookie 8 bishop d2 already not a lot
of move of games in this position
despite the fact that both sides have
played what amounts to be pretty logical
moves there's only
two games in my database and that's kind
of remarkable considering it's a nimzo
indian or move 10 which neither side has
really changed very much but everybody's
looking at pawn takes d5 tons of games
being played theory's developing quickly
but it's not developed yet b6 and we the
players actually played very quickly
here
c5 met with g4 by alireza but it did not
face dominguez it's not the typical
surprise in the opening dominguez goes
into a 30-minute attack no he knew what
he was doing because he replied very
quickly with the move c4 almost
instantly actually challenging this
bishop on d3 it doesn't have many scores
it has to go to f5 takes takes g6 kicks
out the queen before anything else queen
g5 played quickly also by alireza not
exactly a move that you play without
preparation who sticks the queen on g5
instead of c2 without any thought and
also without any thought knight c6
played on the board so despite the fact
that on move 10 we had only two games to
prepare from we've reached mu 15 and we
are still in the preparation of at least
dominguez probably also furuja who has
finally started to think crazy position
the engine probably says oops
didn't mean to do that one
all right
thank you uh the engine of course has
zeros as usual in this position uh but
the plans are clear white wants to
checkmate black and black is saying go
ahead what are you going to do with your
king i'm going to hunt it wherever it
goes they didn't actually suggesting to
castle short but i don't think that's
going to be seen in the game
fascinating struggle the pawn of g4 i'm
not sure it's going to be a weakness or
an acid uh tons of different things to
talk about in this position of course
the weakness on d5 being targeted by the
queen it's tethering this knight but
there's counter checks on g3 you have to
watch out for so knight takes d5 doesn't
work at the moment
i love this game this is the kind of
game i love to see a lot of different
strategical concepts black has space on
the queen side white has space pretty
much everywhere everywhere else this is
a slugfest i think this the players are
going to be happy with what they got
yeah absolutely i'm kind of going to
give wesley so some credit on this one
it seems to me like he's been kind of at
the trailblazer with the e3 bishop d3
queensland yeah we had this game between
wesley and shock in this tournament
which started similar and then went in a
very very different direction and here i
think we had uh american customs wesley
sagan
yes exactly that was the and that was a
great slug festival that was a great
place wow wow wow okay thank you
alejandro we're definitely keeping our
eyes on that one um
how about our leader um
wesley
no all i want yeah
wesley
that's true yeah wesley wesley's having
a kind of a quietish day queen's it very
very reminiscent of that game he had on
the white side of
uh of the same line against mvl i was i
thought that was actually exactly the
same position but maybe
maybe not just just uh and why the small
details might be different yeah i
remember there was a rook a7 rook a7
somewhere yeah
white is a very close to achieving his
ideal one more or less the maximum that
he could ever get as white in this
position essentially because you've
managed to trade the a pawn
for the b5 pawn i get the c4 square so
knight d2 knight c4 is definitely what
white will be aspiring to if he can get
the knight to c4 well maybe fresher on
the queen side but usually it's
considered too
dry it's yeah i mean the b3 is sort of
slightly more protected than the a6 pawn
which is why
it is supposedly a bit of a pull but
wesley did not get very far against mvl
he was actually a bit better in the
final position but i think he only was a
little bit better in the final position
due to some slight inaccuracies by mvl
and it's the exact same position it is
the exact same position the exact same
position yeah the legions database
wasn't really giving me
the very latest games there i think they
it gets updated
after the tournament is finished i guess
yeah let's take a look at the lavon uh
versus fabi game this of course is the
bishop's opening with d3 and knight c6
as you mentioned peter transposing into
the joko piano the drawback of the
bishop's opening it's got to be c7 c6 as
black gets to play d5 right away and
early in the tournament we've had a five
in this position exactly in the game
between uh player r and player a and
player b yeah
yeah exactly and now you get pretty
strong players a and b there yeah so
they should before check without a5 so
the second by far the second main move
up or maybe even the first may move in
this position so the whole point from
white's perspective is white likes a
castle
he loves to play knight c3 put pressure
on the d5 pawn try to provoke d4 and the
bishop comes to life now you can't take
this pawn because now g5 is painful yeah
that's awkward for the second player to
meet so even though it looks strange to
play the move bishop b5 check the whole
idea yeah you're trying to provoke c3 to
deny the knight on the one the square
precisely yeah bishop d2 is by far the
the main er
move here the mainer i like that main
line yeah and there you go i played a
number of games with queen t takes d2 on
the white side of this with with the
white pieces
and uh i had some decent positions but
the my
most recent foray into this line uh
ended with me being like much
much worse by move 11 and like lost by
move 15 with white which is an
achievement i think it's like it's not
that easy to achieve in this line
exactly and uh
levon instead takes with the knight
which is a slightly quieter line i would
suspect because you have given up hopes
on getting it to c3 which is a major
major idea
but you do you do sometimes get very uh
sharp structures anyway because
here after castles if black let's say
castles i am looks natural yeah i'm
expecting
i mean why it's only real uh
ambitious planning these types of
positions is to take on d5 allows it
takes d5 seemingly giving up
control of the center and then pretty
much immediately go g4 e4
and then something either knight t5 in
some cases or perhaps you go something
like knight e1 c2 e3
and try to push f3 later
uh there are issues with knight evan
it's a bit passive knight c2 in this
particular position will be you'll have
to prepare it because a5 a4 is an issue
but 95 is definitely something you can
try i always thought that the idea had
been that uh you did take on d5 but you
end up wanting to put the pressure on
the center and you're kind of happy that
you've induced knight d7 absolutely yeah
but the e5 is reasonably well protected
like rookie yeah rookie one rookie
[Music]
yeah here i think 93 is awkward but b6
bishop b7 is just such a such a
comfortable way to continue supporting
e7b6 yeah and the issue with the planet
you're describing let's say we go on 93
we should be seven here yes
if we don't achieve anything kind of
quickly here with white it starts
looking as if we haven't really
equalized right if you like ghost queen
c7 rkd8 knight c5 you definitely start
preferring black summer oh yeah at some
moment with the knight already asked on
e3 i'm going to try
a theme that that you suggested were
okay
now we're much happier
we're much happy about going 94 perhaps
even knight h4 yeah i was thinking
it it might get stuck after g6 um
quite possibly
yeah yeah but in any case uh it it
it does allow for a fight absolutely
you've got an advantage well
these are these are very interesting
very uh very uh uh
imbalanced positions
and uh statorial advice from livon
iranian as we
very
yeah and this is not available at
cubitique it's the venus yes yet the
bleeding heart the bleeding heart shirt
yeah i mean we had the shark
and now the bleeding hearts i don't know
i mean
but tucked outside
them
it's a goodwill bin
[Laughter]
i'm sure lavon's going to love me for
that one
the set just went down a few notches
there
yes well i'm sure annie is going to be
all fired up as she's doubtlessly
looking at the fashion shops
and i
blundered
but i admit to my mistakes
correct and we do have after knight d7
by the way uh going into the direction
in that game between yon and shaq well
without the inclusion of bishop d5
bishop b6 which i'm not sure
you know who it's very difficult to
judge which things are in whose favor in
these types of positions exactly
everything complicated very very subtle
position yeah right but i want to say
that it's it's very very easy somewhat
surprisingly i think for white to
actually just straight up get mated here
you make some kind of a way like i think
e5v4 is
in this position like a crashing threat
if you do nothing if you play you know
a2 a4 bishop d2 i think this actually
makes my start stronger yeah exactly so
let's go a4 let's not give up let's not
give me additional points okay a4 we go
e4
d4 knight g5
and i don't even want f4 f4 wins but
like my point was more strategically
like i got my g5 id5 i followed up with
a four and f three and i think
uh yeah
this already looks like you white just
gets swept off the board here yeah you
just have no squares and the attack on
the king side will probably be decisive
and that's not even touching the point
that fdx was winning on the spawn i was
more afraid of that which uh unmasks uh
the attack of the rook and the bishop
you have to be you have to be very
cognizant of of you know getting getting
completely avoiding checkmating
but by the way uh just the importance of
the game between these two players again
they're all bunched up on at the top and
for ian a victory would hit the
trampoline and he would be uh looking at
a place finish plus possible is
currently completely unoccupied so yeah
exactly it would he would
do good things to his tournaments and
conversely our defending champion shakri
are looking for his first victory in the
tournament uh quite a contrast between
last year and this year and a win will
get him to 50
but
oh
yeah he's had a tough event oh yeah
yeah ooh
that that that's tough but uh
yeah what can i say and ian's uh
going to the candidate so uh some he
needs some enthusiasm as he prepares for
madrid knight g3
it's a novelty
it's a novelty that everybody's
considered right this is like if you
look at get to this position and you
think bishop defies the main line that's
true but what happens on knight g3 right
i think everybody looks at this exactly
you want to break the pin and uh i'm
also a bit curious why bishop v6 is so
horrible but bishop 3 is just basically
why you play this line so maybe you
don't even need a particular reason
not to play bishop g6 but the inclusion
of king h8 bishop g6 i mean even if i
went d4 maybe yeah it's possible
i mean i think we should be six it's
unclear
h4h5 might not be that stupid here
actually so much right right right
i i mean the this is the the
continuation that black uh showed is
certainly in the spirit absolutely the
king h8 uh thing and and
as you said yourself very very uh
happily uh so if you let black go e5 e4
it needs to be sidestepped yeah yeah
yeah
you're out of here yeah i'm wondering
exactly sidestep
i'm wondering how because
you're kind of short on uncomfortable
comfortable moves here you can
try knight h5 but they just look so
artificial where they like first of all
i don't know what the answer to g6 is
i'm afraid i'm afraid that my queen is
actually just wholly misplaced on the
file where does it go after knight of
six
is my first question
okay i'm just uh i mean yasser's eyes
no maybe not but i can hang i can hang
and
and now i'm very tempted by him now
after bishop f2 we cry yeah yeah first
of all once again
f2
on point and i'll play knight e4 hoping
you take rook takes c4
c4 check and i win more material
that's cruel i'm so pleased that i
defended my king no you didn't discover
check my friend ouch yeah okay so i
can't my queen can't hang out on the um
the kings well you can you can go all
the way back to e2 but then why aren't
we starting we're starting with weenie
too
it's you know queen h4 makes perfect
sense there to me and
uh after queen e2
honestly i would still at least be
looking at e5 before
well i don't know if it's any good but
i'd be i'd be interested to at least
check it out definitely i also like your
queen h4 by the way nh4 i i thought you
can play like king h2 and it doesn't do
very very much but maybe it's a good
inclusion simply for black and then we
do whatever we want maybe we do the same
but with the inclusion of those two
moves well also what's it's a it's a
situation
what's also kind of confusing for me is
like
you know i'm so happy i've got this
great e4 square for my knight but that's
about it this bishop on d2 pardon me
this bishop on c1 is kind of suffering
and i don't know this is this is
something that they do in this line
quite a bit yeah just play a 504 which
seems like it breaks every single every
single rule in the book but uh maybe not
yeah it's a kind of a reverse lasker
capoblanca from
yes exactly sorry yeah
yeah the entire point of the move is
just to restrict the bishop on c1 to
such an extent that uh it trumps all
other considerations
and i don't know if it's the best move
against queen so but it definitely is
uh heavily heavily considered in pretty
much every single position here
just to make it difficult for white to
include those pieces does it does it
makes sense to do
i mean
upon sacrifice in every single position
this makes sense yeah and maybe bishop
before correct that was just what i was
thinking like go ahead take my pawn on
c3 i think the biggest issue you have to
have an answer to g5 i think precisely i
wouldn't take on c3
exactly and this is like opening files
for you for your pieces yeah this is
where you start to see the blossoming of
the two bishops but you're making a very
very good point just immediate g5 try to
chase it away and go knight e5 exactly
exactly get some squares from you for my
things help me out here
by the way i i'm floundering uh
alejandro let nepo think he's remember
his lines looking look you can see how
he's postured he's not really thinking
over the board as much as he's trying to
remember his variations trying to
remember what his files say obviously
knight g3 something that he must have
thought about before he's played bishop
d5 himself against levon so he's
familiar with the variation he's just
remembering yeah and he did play the
move d4 which is one of the things we
considered with darius when we prepared
this variation because it is topical to
sacrifice upon and hope for the best
i got an idea how about this peter how
about night h5 i think
i mean you inspired me to win an
exchange
russian school boy knows rooks are
better than knights
yeah i can i can see i can see that
being interesting even though
it feels like it's kind of not fast
enough but maybe maybe i wanted to go
knight five knight g6 but then you can
maybe go knight of four anyway
ooh but also i got a tempo
yeah g5
queen d6 and maybe then knight before
yeah it's getting kind of annoying yeah
i'm a good rookie six that's a kind of a
threat i i i feel that i've got good
players
and i think that black woman and that
brings me that brings me to i think a
potentially salient point here either
hd4 is not forced i think bishop b6 is
definitely something you could
give some thought
i don't think i don't think the pawn is
going away i don't think gtx e5 is a
move white no no no i'm not interested
in
i mean again the spirit of d4 is not too
in
not to get your pieces
uh on outstanding kind of a larger point
of bishop b6 is that i would like to
start by playing a five of four
and only after the night goes somewhere
i want to maybe consider it takes d4
then gotcha
makes sense so
i'm trying to remember there was a very
spectacular game between i think maxime
matlakov and levon
which
there was definitely a game in
in adjacent positions where
black played a 4 in white played knight
h5
and later that knight on h5 got
sacrificed
after g6 it was just left there
basically and white played like gtx e5
and d6
but i can't i can't recall exactly how
the game went because right now none of
this works because gtx e5 will not be
met by gtx h5 in this position of course
black will take only five first and it's
completely winning
i yeah and uh i have these kind of hazy
memories of
actually you know
yeah
google is my friend yeah you're you're
you're not exactly at the con at a
tournament competition you're allowed to
look at yourself
database here um
okay well we're gonna let nepo and shaq
uh share their homework together what
are you gonna share with us uh alejandro
commentators can cheat we have the
engine and we have the databases and
it's good life but somebody that doesn't
have a database is maxima sherlock and
he's trying to figure out how to
navigate the queen's gambit accepted
it's not his main opening perhaps he
switched into it but of course we know
that the years and years and years of
building up that experience in the
groomfield allowed him to really
manipulate the opening however he wanted
and these grandmasters have played some
of their openings so many times that it
doesn't matter which variation you
surprise them with they still know all
of the plans they know all of the ideas
they know the transpositions into the
different variations very very well but
when you're just starting out when
you're just a qga player uh starting out
perhaps you're not familiar with all of
them and richie's played an incredibly
clever move order check this out
bishop takes a4 a6 automatic here is to
castle everybody plays castles and then
they think on the next move however a4
has been seen transposing into some
positions lately and richie played as a
very cagey move bishop b3 which at the
beginning doesn't seem to pose any real
problems because after c5 what else can
you do you castle right this is the
natural but richie had no interest in
that he played the move knight c3
actually keeping his king in the center
for a little bit longer so that on b5 he
didn't castle he played the move e4 so
now it's a real challenge on max team on
how do you how do you follow up you
could play b4 and try to get that pawn
you could take on d4 but white gets a
huge setter or you could develop
normally now there's a lot of
possibilities here for black it's a
relatively unexplored territory only
four games wow in this position kind of
crazy including a gristrok vs kramnik
game which i do not remember this game
at all but sasha beat big vlad in 2018
here so bishop b7
was played by maxime and richard didn't
think very long and actually played the
move d5 which he must have had as a
preparation against some other game
because this particular position does
not exist however
like in a rare occurrence we're gonna
have two novelties in this game of chess
because this is a novelty but it
transposes back to something we have
already played c4 bishop c2 knight bd7
chosen by maxime actually if you see my
right side of the screen it pops up
again there have been players that have
gone into this position via a different
move order and maybe that's why after
knight bd7 instantly richard richard
played castles transposing into one of
the lines of the queen's gambit accepted
that i'm not sure if maxine plays
because he's thinking in this position
however you check out the database this
is this is just a clear i mean this is
the marin right this is this is ameren
yes this is ameren this is a very weird
transposition
into one of the absolute like classical
main lines of the maryland which i think
like in my mind it's associated mainly
with the with the name of alexandrev but
yeah exactly i wanted to say the
girlfriend of game yeah it it is
maximum
player exactly he is now
we will all be
[ __ ] players and also uh karpov had
some very instructed games in this in
this line on the white side of it but
yeah drev has written books on the topic
and played like dozens of
dozens of games starting from somewhere
around here even i like have some you
know
vague ideas of how this goes and
floating in my head
by the way uh i saw that you had gotten
that database uh yeah that scene what
was the move order the the the muslic of
our onion game is from 2019 world cup
it's it's basically from this line but
it didn't go exactly like this because
matlakov played
uh
a line with bhp seven instead of knight
g7
uh so uh
that is that is obviously very i mean
it's it's similar in in spirit but yeah
if you go bishop b7 here they include a4
a5 somewhere uh so let's let's say here
it doesn't really matter when knight g3
bishop f3 uh take stakes
f5 and it went let me tell you exactly
how it went yeah so here
maxim played d4
left responded with
f4 knight h5 g6
d5 gh
this is a very very unclear position
which maxim kind of misplayed almost
immediately and was in a lot of trouble
and ended up losing the game but this is
a very sharp position which uh yeah you
can you can definitely
get a lot of play here if you play
precisely even though black i think
holds which before i think the problem
is before bishop g5 specifically uh
maxim did take on h5 and was met with a
very strong move queen d3 which is
potentially what he missed originally
but yeah it was a very sharp game which
i remember they they had sort of great
fun playing it and then like
half the tournament ended up discussing
it outside because it was a very
very exciting
game a different approach not the bishop
e7 but it it it's nice that you have
that in your mind as a as something that
you were weighing and how a knight got
stranded on h5 yeah it wasn't an unusual
enough occurrence of why just going
knight h5 knowing it's not going to come
back that i it's stuck in my head but
yeah the game today continued as we sort
of expected
and you you you just uh planted a very
salient question to me but i think we go
bishop
d5 queen h5 and then these kingside
pawns start hanging a little bit so for
a moment ago you were you were killing
me with these beautiful ideas of f5 f4
f3
and now that you put your pawn on g5
you got some regrets
about going ballistic
yes but
specifically like the reason i was so
excited about black's prospects was
uh all of my all of my ideas were very
much with the file closed yes and
like if you remember
that line i started bringing up where
ge4f4 was winning on the sport and i was
very specifically playing knight g5 and
then f4 kind of a you know king's
indian-ish idea of you know sacrificing
a pawn to create a blockading square in
front of it right and with the center
reasonably well closed you are a lot
happier uh going for this uh attacks on
this thing this is the type of situation
you're saying closed e5 yeah i mean no
in particular 4g 4 and then f4 was the
the idea like uh sorry e4g for you but
uh
the the position we have yeah let's
let's look at this this is the game
let's look at this
uh what we have on the screen here is a
a much more kind of a loose position for
black because the center is still very
much open both bishops are now very much
in play working yeah rook 81 coming next
i'm guessing if if you just give white a
move here the move comes kind of
automatically you go to kg1 although
some consideration has to be given to
rookie six i quite like e6 i know that
e6 for the rook and then double on the
evo uh e file also looks very attractive
in basketball it would be like posting
up on the e6 square it looks attractive
but on the other hand it's a pawn it is
a pawn and uh can can black uh find a
way to utilize the e5 i'm looking at
bishop d6 right now exactly that was the
first move that kind of went into it
it's a it's a bit of a sad move because
it feels like maybe we're trying to
equalize and we're not born now but the
more i look at this position the more i
feel that maybe trying to equalize is
where is where the game is at right now
and again
you know you like looking at the best
position the best pieces for white
trading them off not a bad idea
alejandro jump right in
learning from previous mistakes it's
something chess players always need to
do i have analyzed this position in
particular uh after the move
uh go to right here the material graph
game d4 in this position with the
inclusion of bishop d5 and bishop b6 so
this is not the game that we have on the
board here it's slightly different but
the same style of structure and after
the moves f4 this is the game between
mvl and darius that we kept referencing
94 queen h4 this was all prep uh up to
this point and mvl went to a huge thing
came out with an amazing movie came up
with the move knight
which is super cool wow best piece for
white needs to move so it can capture
this bishop on b6 but it was actually a
genius idea it really was context d4 was
correct knight c4 and here darius also
went into the into the tank thinking
about what he needed to do he didn't
really come up with the proper idea the
problem is that after the move rook d8
bishop c6 pawn takes c6 bishop d2 this
configuration turned out to be very
difficult for black to deal with because
you never want to take on c3 bishop
takes c3 just comes too powerful the
bishop becomes too good it
basically kills the idea of f4 which is
to kill the bishop on d2 so it was
difficult to take on c3 bishop takes e3
and activate the bishop there was no
good way to solve the tension in the
center despite the extra point and we
all went on to win a great game if we go
back to the position that we have
currently
without the move bishop d5 here so we
have f5
am i missing something knight g3 bishop
takes queen takes f5 he's played d4 pawn
takes bishop f4 right
so in this position we have a very
similar scenario every time that you
scare my bishop away with a move like g5
and put my bishop on d2 i can no longer
take on c3 and resolve the central
tension the engines are saying take on
c3 because it forces white to define how
you want to do this do you want to take
with the queen which is a little awkward
or do you want to take with the pawn but
now bishop d2 c3 is not a threat after
pawn takes c3 now i can play the move g5
utilize this tempo
and if the bishop comes to d2 knight d
e5 thank you for the tempo on the bishop
on d2 and otherwise you have to go all
the way to c1 yes it looks a little
scary to open up your king like this
bishop c1 bishop b2c4 but if you
calculate it out it's not really that
much of a problem because the bishop
doesn't have that many great squares
down the diagonal i'll be able to chase
it away in many of them even in
scenarios where you open up the diagonal
i could play bishop d4 and exchange
those guys so it comes down to the
specifics of the position that bishop c1
is under developing your position
fascinating position here between these
two players d takes c3 the engines are
saying mandatory played already played
already played exactly yeah i remember
the
my scholastics days where you're doing
the danish gambit you know d4 the guy
takes you go c3 the guy takes you you
develop your pieces the guy takes and
you're all very happy i hear alejandra
loud and clear you're all very happy
yeah
i know i i i matured
it took me a while but i got there um it
it whether you take it with the pawn on
c3 whether you take with the queen on c3
you may be not happy uh maybe are you
going home yeah but i mean i i will
continue danish gambiting here right
like i would like to go see the xb2 if i
can c takes b and i think i can because
bishop b6 bishop d6 actually solves my
immediate problems
not to mention maybe my differences
good yeah i can't exploit this as wow
i'm not sure
but i would like to be as many pawns up
as possible here because i feel like i
will very soon have to start returning
them yes but at the worst case scenario
you're going to return b2 right i mean
worst case scenario promote up queen and
yeah and that's the tempo
draws away away from uh
and it is a few pawns no question about
it
okay um
d take c3 and uh as you said computer
recommended so we've got to uh assume
that it's definitely on ian's uh
you wouldn't think so right you don't
you don't sacrifice this palm without
knowing the proper variation the engine
wants to play and if i do
capture with the queen i know you said
it was i should before is
a thing right bishop b4 is the thing of
course it is it's a thing right that's a
thing i mean uh
those rooks are less
higher valued than yeah i mean
white does have very very nice looking
bishops but it's a full exchange very
much i think so too
oh dear uh bishop before so i think you
might actually kind of have to start
looking at uh at those positions
alejandra was describing earlier g5 i go
bishop c1 i think unhappily and ideal
knight g5 queen h5 and i hope that this
somehow works out
if not in my favor then at least you
know sort of playable for white bishop
293 immediate 93 is also a move it
starts to look a little bit unpleasant
maybe because of that the screen h5 move
the engine wanted to put the c knight on
e5
interesting queen h5 and then knight f6
f4 and last of six maybe yeah yeah f4
knight f6 maybe four and another six
possibly although
i don't know yeah
i'm having i i want to show you a
particular diagram here just uh only
good morning saint louis
style yes yeah queen h5 no no if we
bring up the just it's it's going to
take one second please the uh
dominguez game oh i'm sorry yeah just on
the on the topic of how this morning is
going for me
for the one up yeah from from there yeah
so uh
linear played h7h6
on the previous move
yeah
h6 yeah and i saw h6 and i thought okay
bishop takes h6 knight takes g4 and
takes d8 takes d8
right and i got to some weird position
where black isn't exchanged down but
there is some positional compensation
and then i thought there might be
something wrong with this calculation
and knight takes e3 uh specifically that
bishop takes h6 is not a legal move
right
but this reminds me of grizzlies i hate
that yeah yeah gristrok's bishop h6
against favi right yeah yeah oh
that was
horrifying one move loss of the bishop
yeah for those that are not familiar
there was a queen on c1 there was a
bishop on e3 and grishik was gearing to
kill the dragon bishop with bishop h6
unfortunately there was also a knight on
d2
yeah you you had to see his face when
bishop takes h6 was replied to why
bishop takes it no but
you know what was most surprising to me
about that video was never chris
christian's reaction i thought it was
very natural you know oh my god i left
the piece on pre it was that favi
captured on h6
like he expected that yeah
it's like oh now normal move when he
used to reply
he was not at least a little shocked
right
nice
just as my blueprint had
had it going there okay um
sorry uh h6 uh i just wanted to finish
our thought of where we do stand on this
uh no that's not the game that's not the
game that is the game this is the game
uh where where do we stand right here in
terms of
this position let's say if i do take uh
i'm very unsure about how the shakes are
i think we would g5 yeah we would need
to continue calculating it's it's very
committal move oh and the good old
informants we have a sign for this the
infinity sign unclear
by the way that was really the bane of
uh i i hated that sign in particular
because
it was sort of like i'm looking for an
answer not you know uh you you sold it
yourself it's a co-pilot
yeah but it was a very useful cop-out
because right other times you just
didn't know so basically like there are
two extremes there right you you like
you give a three-ply variation with a
with an infinity sign on the end or
alternatively you could be dr robert
hubner yes and just yeah and you know 20
sub variations and your game you know
lasts for five pages of information and
that's no war like for those of you who
have not grown up with informants that
features zero wars it's only the moves
right yeah uh and uh yeah i
had the privilege of playing for the
same team with uh with dr hogner and
yeah he really really liked looking for
truth right and that very much shown
through in in the way he annotated games
so just to help people out so they the
idea was it was a lange
language-less
annotation so the idea was like i don't
speak mandarin chinese but if i if i use
this code of symbols i can explain what
i was thinking a better move was this
interesting
dubious uh i blundered here most of
those abbreviations actually survived
and are now incorporated into uh into
let's say chess base which is uh right
exactly universal language of chess now
but exactly but yeah the informant were
the first one to to pioneer the idea of
a you know chess periodical which would
be accessible to everyone who you know
took the time to to understand the
legend of those signs yeah and it was a
fair amount of science yeah 26 30
something like that yeah yeah yeah
a lot of them a lot of them and there
was one particular annotator dr robert
hubner who like you said in this quest
for truth would have pages and pages
and i think there was one guy who said
okay
i'm going to challenge doctor robert
hoover it was gary caspar
i went like 20 pages occasionally yeah
like it's just like what you know like
these two guys arguing it out at the
summit of their
i think i think uh
dr hebner at some point had a book of uh
favorite game games published and uh it
was like a full length like a reasonably
thick book and probably featured like 10
games
and you're not exaggerating i don't
think i don't think i'm much
exaggerating very much and it's a very
like i i don't own it
uh but that's just mainly because at
some point i
kind of started slacking off on buying
chess books but i'm pretty sure it's
worth it because
the way he thought about chess and the
way he thought i mean he's just a very
very uh you know interesting and unique
character and uh yes uh
i i had to i i got to you know have a
few train rides together with him too
and from bundesliga and you know talk to
him on various subjects and
those are very fond memories he's
a very very interesting person an
extraordinarily well-read person as well
um do we have more
more moves in this game no i think we're
we're up to date uh over to you
alejandro what's happening in our queen
in our newly minted mvl queen's gambit
accepted
ah this is a pure american it's just
america
yeah
actually i wonder if leech has updated
uh crazy i haven't accepted no it didn't
technology six tech 26 knight g5 has
been seen hundreds of times you get some
really top-level games here you've got
kansas cheer karma of kramnik kramnik
sheriff all kinds of players have been
using this setup for a while it's not
the marin line of the day i would say
that so many other maron variations are
being played nowadays more than this one
but it still retains an extreme amount
of sharpness you don't remember your
opening lines here you'll you could just
die knight c5 is four so i think
everybody who has played this we did see
the move queen c6 here in saint louis
blunder in one of the cairns cups i
remember that karpov played queen c6
against conero and lost am i correct yes
kaipav against canaro and lost and now
that's the other game canero played it
with white against goonina and gordina
won queen c6 and got obliterated because
queen 6 is a very bad move knight c5 is
the move that you're supposed to play
and hundreds of games have been played
from there but it's funny that the move
queen c6 had been played a couple of
times including one here at the st louis
chess club absolutely uh just uh
checking in also
as we prepare for a break between the
vaughn and fabi again this was the
big dry and um
just feels like black is actually black
is one more
one move away from completely equalizing
you would assume and yeah if you get
this b6 and you'll no longer have a
single issue
exactly but uh levana's been blitzing as
we can see there's a pretty big time
difference between the two players i
mean he may be blitzing out of his moves
uh peter but does he have anything to
show i don't know
i think so you know and uh yeah as you
correctly pointed out there b6 is a
major idea including bishop g4 might not
be stupid either exactly i actually
thought maybe we'd go knight e4 but it
just came from there
it's
an awkward move to take back if you will
and black will not be too unhappy about
taking and having a symmetrical by the
way i'm still laughing about the comment
that alejandro made in
the game of shakir shaq when shaq went
knight
a6 he said you know if you gave me this
position for the first time what would
you do as black i would play transplants
please bring it back
back to civilization
and alejandro uh this is the drier
queen's gambit uh
except the other one's not a queen's
governor except let's stop calling yeah
yeah okay okay
all right this one is very dry we know
we know that that came in with the same
idea that wesley had previous in the
tournament with the move b3 let's see
where the deviation comes around here
bishop f3 instead of the move queen d7
defending the bishop here wesley decided
it's okay to take on f3 take one f3 and
play rook a7 the idea is that after rook
c1 this knight on b8 is not developed
quite yet and might not be developed
immediately because remember there is
some pressure on the a6 pawn by this
rook on a4 the moment you move the
knight it will increase also this knight
is eyeing c6 so
what is a developed piecing chest it's a
piece that's doing something useful the
knight on v8 it wants to come back into
the game fully but it is doing something
useful on b8 it is defending c6 and it's
defending a6 it's developed that could
be an argument uh the problem with the
rook is that it's
not going uh towards the rest of the
pieces unless you have the move rook c7
which is played immediately so this
solves the problem with the rook the
knight is going to stay on b8 you're not
really playing for a huge advantage as
black but it's very solid it's very
close to equality as well
rook c7 is currently on the board dak
has been thinking for a while as he
usually does it doesn't seem like wesley
has any real problems the engine thinks
you should take take knight d2 but it
doesn't create
that many real threats the rook could
come to d8 you can even play bishop f8
at some point he has some issues with
the a6 bomb but it's not it's such a
small target very difficult to get to it
and it's so easily defended by a knight
that's already on the rim
is it fully equal i don't know but is it
within a heavy drawing range for these
two players very heavy
uh for me i didn't understand the move
rook c1 i thought that kind of helped
black actually to get rid of his problem
rook how about knight a3 let's just put
the knight on c4 first maybe i'll keep
the rook on
af1 going to either d1 or a1 on a good
day yeah perhaps perhaps it would have
been more precise i i do agree that the
move rook c1 seems to simplify black's
last
uh the entrance are not impressed with
anything in this position for them
everything is like plus point one plus
point two uh it wants to play queen d5
but anything you can play h6 you can
play rook c7 you can play a lot of moves
so getting the my knight to c4 which i
really wanted to do isn't
isn't that great as shakes
it doesn't really change the character
of the position that much it's a nice
night you keep some pressure but the
knight itself doesn't have a clear plan
where to go to right you could go to e5
it gets kicked out go to a5 you have
problems with the fact that you're
blocking your own rook so yeah it's nice
it's no i think everybody takes white in
this position compared to black but if
you were to guarantee that white's going
to win from these positions you almost
never do that no no no no fair enough
thank you for that alejandro and can we
just
pop in to ali raja's game against lanier
because uh that actually
with the pawn on g4 most especially yeah
it does and
uh queen h4 h3 i like the move bishop h6
i like i like the way you're thinking uh
grab that pawn peter uh rook d one yeah
okay he i mean he is prep is there some
indication that he wants to play for
quickly or just oh i think it's it's
very much so i i do believe that's his
attack i don't think it works just yet
but it definitely is something on his
mind yeah right i think currently e4 g4
doesn't so for example let's just make a
port a choice a d4
yeah i think i take one h6 take on f3
take on g4 i think it works out fine for
yeah no uh
no
major issues here it takes a four exists
but i'm not that unhappy about having to
play five here to be honest
i have a pawn up and uh you've also
destroyed your own king side and uh
currently there is not very much in the
way of threads d5 knight c5 only
improves my position
right um i mean it's an unclear position
but i i wouldn't feel
that i'm getting mated that's scared
yeah okay okay
let's just jump into our colleagues in
bucharest with anastasia and christian
thank you yasser actually anastasia you
were mentioning uh johanna richie's wife
at the beginning of the broadcast and
the active role that she's playing as a
second for richie who is such a strong
player but also uh i i want to highlight
the seconds because they're so important
and they're very often overlooked for
these players and i saw a few a couple
of new fresh faces quite interesting
linear dominguez in particular he showed
up with a second that i haven't seen
before that that is emilio cordova from
peru i know these two players know each
other from st louis and emilio used to
be a student at webster university close
to saint louis so they definitely
created a a partnership there and
another uh new name is actually hyrulin
ildar from russia who is the second of
jan nepomnyashi that's another face that
i haven't seen
since my childhood i was actually
playing in the same tournaments youth
tournaments european and world
championships with uh ildar and it's
great to see him finally make that jump
and a second such a strong player as yan
uh anastasia how about yourself you were
mentioning something about you wanna
tell us a bit about that and i also
wanted to say that normally we're used
to see uh jan nippon she was vladimir
podkin right but now we saw some photos
from uh russia that he was playing in
the club championship so maybe he was
just busy and
actually yeah i mentioned uh ivana today
and i think it's really great uh that uh
we spoke about family business it's
really great that she's helping her her
husband and to imagine finding the
novelties which kind of kill
kill grunfeldt of maxima i don't seem to
see him playing gruntful so often after
that game and i don't know it feels like
maybe she i don't know that yet but
maybe they managed to surprise maxim
today as well because he spends quite a
lot of time during the game and we see
already 20 minutes
gap between them and um i wonder if the
preparation also worked today and it's
really nice that richie always speaks
about her and always
speaks about her support i always try to
find out if he has any other seconds but
he never says about anyone else and i'm
sure that peter and the other who have
so much experience um and played in the
candidates they know how important to
have a good team of supporters
especially before such an important
event but we don't hear anything about
it so i was wondering if you have any
other information absolutely and as you
were mentioning richie is quite
secretive about his seconds and the
players that he's working with and i do
believe that mvl probably the grunfeld
that you were mentioning was one of his
last losses in the groomfeld and we saw
him in this tournament trying to shy
away in the game against wesley so as
well as in this one he starts off with
d5 quite a new approach for mvl
definitely some tendencies to avoid the
grunfeld interesting approach and as you
were mentioning
i do want to ask yasser peter and
alejandro what do they think the role of
a second should be should they be only
analyzing should they be emotional
support
what's the balance what what has to be
the balance there guys
i think you said it well uh there is a
balance and it is emotional support it's
just that spiritual go get em tiger that
you wanna hear as well as yeah i checked
the line and it's perfectly good you can
play it yeah i think ideally there you
know uh and ideally there needs to be a
a balance in the of that in the same
person like for me uh
uh
people i've worked with over the course
of uh
of my career people i mean people who
hired me perhaps have a different
opinion but when i talk about people who
were helping me for to prepare for
candidates i always
thought that
uh
an emotional connection and a kind of a
level of friendship is a
pre-requirement because otherwise you
know you're going to spend a lot of time
with this person right uh looking in
chess
and if there is absolutely no connection
on a human level it's not going to be a
particularly enjoyable experience and i
was very very happy and though very
fortunate to have uh people like that
help me
along the way and on the topic of
seconds being there yeah shout out to
baton uh
yanni bonnie she actually sent me a
picture of him and an ildar flying into
bucharest and i failed to recognize
hilda talking about my facial he did he
did grow a reasonably you know cushy
cushy beard but still like we've played
for for the same club for like five
years straight it's it's inexcusable you
should have seen through the beard yeah
i i apologize it's it's but he's been
helping uh jan for quite some time it's
just perhaps been slightly under the
surface but they've been friends for
forever and ever and uh
working together let's get ollie yeah
alejandro you you've definitely been
both second as well as having people
help you i remember you're playing so
well in the u.s championship uh tell me
uh
uh christian's idea what what's what's
the balance
that's a tough one right because as
peter said you spent so
much time together it's like for when
favi
christian dominguez and rustam and i we
were preparing for the world
championship as a team
it was months i mean it was month you
spend with on the same house with these
people you never really got breaks right
you would go to like the supermarket you
go to the restaurants but besides that
you probably spend like every waking
minute with them
uh so you kind of have to like them you
don't like them it's a pretty miserable
experience but i felt that it was a
tough balance because you are doing a
ton of work but you're also there to
support your player uh things don't
always go according to plan sometimes
everybody has to
do things that they're not particularly
part of the contract uh as my boss here
the signal is chess club likes to say
other duties as assigned and you find
yourself doing a lot of that right not
specifically chess so of course there's
a big deal on you know chassis and
analysis and openings and stuff like
that but getting your player to a point
where they're comfortable in their skin
playing chess the best possible way that
that's the main job of the second and
how that comes together i think is very
individual to every player
well said by the way as we prepare for
our break in the game of richard and mvl
it did seem to take maxine a while to
recognize that queen c6 as played by
karpov and others it's actually just a
bad move as queensland
and queen h3 and you're tickling this
big big weakness on e6 whereas knight c5
vastly superior theory of this yeah all
those carpool share of games and kramnik
share of games it goes e5 i've been
wondering why 5 has not met with queen
c6 but i'm sure there is a reason um
e5 is the e5 is the main move after
knight c5
and the game's kind of automatically
continue queen takes e5 rookie one queen
d6
yeah
over 800 those are probably computer
games mainly but yeah like queen takes
the six or bishop 86 bishop e3
castles yeah all of these like this is
the uh the absolute classics and some of
them were won by white but but i think
by this point it's supposed to be kind
of a force draw after bishop c5 bishop
c5 96 rook fc8
i think it's been equalized uh by uh by
machines basically by this point uh i'll
take your word for it that that the line
goes very very deeply as we prepare for
bake uh we've got some uh thing from q
boutique what's our special today fam
uh friends and family discount of five
percent still peter possibly possibly
what do we get yeah today today we're
showing you uh traditional stunts oh no
that's not that that's for the future
apologies on the thursday yes celebrate
the grandchild store it says with a
limited edition 2022 t-shirt and there
you see very prominently uh
the
the
baggage tag the same yeah the baggage
tags yeah features all of the stops
along the tour on the back of the shirt
and the saint louis chess club logo on
the right sleeve uh as with uh most
other things we're showing you uh on
this program it is available at
cubitiquestl.com
uh your one-stop shop for
chess related
shopping wonderful we'll see you on the
other side of our break
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end has
established itself as a premier global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the us
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the u.s and world chess halls
of faint
cutting edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art innovative programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries
the world chess hall of fame is nothing
you expect and everything you love three
different galleries and a premier gift
shop highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game come visit
play chess leave enriched
to learn more about the st louis chess
campus visit stl stlchesscampus.org
[Music]
st louis university celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st louis
slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe
in 2015 slu partnered with the st louis
chess club to start a top-tier
collegiate chess team on the very first
year of the teen's inception slu
obtained second best university at the
pan american intercollegiate chess
championships
higher purpose greater good
st louis university
[Music]
we're the corey family welcome to our
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys gonna see this
that's our show now go start yours at
this moment.com
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and as you can see on your screen one
game has already finished the one we
were sort of uh overselling perhaps a
little bit before the before the start
of the round uh because the percentage
of decisive games prior to the day
between levon and and fabi is staggering
for two players absolutely habitually
over 2800 at some point of their careers
but today it's been a very quiet affair
22 uh
decisive games and 25 drawings
i think it was 26 but it's still up like
a 45 uh decisive games this was the
bishop's opening game with bishop to d2
and the play well let's face it uh
was rather quiet throughout nothing
really happened it just seemed like more
pieces kept coming off and the moment we
saw this
directly during our break so that you
say okay lavonne he's in first place or
at least tight for first i don't i don't
think he's
down i don't know that was his intention
prior to the game but it definitely
became his intention somewhere around
here when he realized he has nothing and
he might as well you know not you know
shuffle the pieces around
and uh updated standings with this game
being finished uh levon isn't in the
lead but that is with you know against
wesley having game in hand so
wesley if he doesn't lose today will at
least catch up exactly his position is
very dry so you don't really expect him
to to win from that qga that he has on
the board so very likely we will have
steal a diaper first my pick to win the
tournament fabiano the american cup
champion is only at 50 percent only
fifty percent which is like the the vast
majority of the tournaments
percent and after 94 uh they they traded
and after
more trades and
well more trades yeah the one the one
move that is perhaps slightly noteworthy
for our viewers here is this move after
xc6 which seems counterintuitive if i
spoil a structure like this but control
over the open file is just way more
important here than uh than spoiling the
uh the king-size structure and it
immediately forces a drop because white
cannot really tolerate uh leaving the
roconji too unchallenged absolutely and
this is a mechanism you see very very
often of uh repeating repeating
repeating the position it's a very
logical repetition here with because if
you give white a couple of moves with
only two rooks on the board you don't
really worry about the e65 weaknesses
that much but generally speaking
allowing king of turnkey to king of king
youtube would be a strange thing to do
here with black exactly once king e2 you
cover all the business squares and maybe
maybe these double pawns do get
to be tickled
anyway a well played draw what can i say
alejandro draw draw draw
yeah i mean it'll be a solid game
between these two yeah not much to speak
about it we can move on from that game
let's do it all right we have this game
between uh firuja and lanier
fascinating struggle here
white has played the move rook d1
hinting at the fact that e4 could be
playable because bishop takes h6 perhaps
they could even take back who finalized
a lot of these lines
in preparation linear as usual took a
long thing and played the move b5 now
he's preparing himself to go before
maybe even a5 b4 in certain positions if
you take on b5 of course here i'm gonna
have rook b8
because i haven't thrown in the move a5
just yet i do always have a6 to push the
knight back if i need to and then take
on b2 no reason to allow the rook on the
set on the second rank b59 will not be
met by knight takes e5 the question is
what do you do against the principled e4
and this is where it could get really
really sharp d takes d4 seems more or
less forced you don't want to allow the
move e5 you're also hanging the pawn on
h6
d takes e4 bishop takes h6 would be a
logical continuation and here things get
crazy the agents are giving some inhuman
lines in certain variations for example
pawn takes f3 you could take on f3 i
don't think that i would consider pawn
takes f3 very seriously as a human
because i see first of all rook f3 rook
h3 is helping white
and because once you spot bishop g5
bishop takes f6 you're still you're
starting to wonder if you're just
straight up lost
interestingly the edges think that after
takes takes and this brilliant but
beautiful move bishop g7
i'll let you guys go through the
variations there
bishop g7 equalizes the game and we're
going to go down these lines because
it's a bit of a rabbit hole but first
we're going to go with christian who has
levon out on with him
thank you alejandro levon welcome back
uh to the studio at the beginning of the
broadcast i did mention your game as a
highlight at least for me because you
said that you're looking for revenge
after the american cup did the strategy
change at any point or when in in the
game during the game did that strategy
change if at any point uh
yeah i think
somehow it didn't really go the way i
expected in the opening i was thinking
to
you know get something
more playable without revealing too much
you started off with uh the bishop's
opening did you want to avoid the the
petrov or what was the name
i wanted to have a surprise just have a
surprise get a game yeah yeah and then i
think
yeah somehow i really forgot what i was
intending to do in this bishop before
stuff because well
there's so many
other moves i mean a5 is very popular
and
uh and there was a game played here
already
and this event yes
yeah
so yeah i remembered
i remembered that i thought that maybe
this is playable but then i forgot that
i actually played uh a game like this
against pogba already he did in a blitz
game he did yeah and he actually it
seems like he played quite a couple of
times against magnus himself and uh
one of the main proponents and it seems
like you also play the game with the
black pieces against nepal did you
remember that yet actually not
no i just uh well honestly i didn't
think that the fabiano is going to go
for this i thought he will play
something else and then uh
yeah i thought uh
okay uh
the principle was to take ed but uh
i couldn't really see what's what's
great with my position and here okay
knight g3 is kind of a little try
because rookie one bishop f5 is finished
it's totally drawn
but uh yeah queen d6 i think just let's
do draw and it's not like i was
you know
so keen to play something risky or
something i just thought that i should
give a little try and things don't work
i'm in a good situation and well i'm
playing white which is the new
we discussed that yesterday and the
black has the new white so i
you know i have to play solid speaking
of that you're actually going to have a
very difficult game tomorrow against
nepo himself the challenger for the
world crown last year uh are you in any
way shape or form fearful of let's say
his preparation at all or i'm fearful of
everybody
okay that's the way you're supposed to
be and when you're fearful you feel like
you're playing better chess
when i'm more conservative or well the
thing is i'm so
self-confident
that from time to time i have to
force myself to be fearful
and i think this this is a lesson i
learned from
mike tyson because he said
because
he had the same
approach he was very
self-confident he said i had to remind
myself that i can get knocked out every
second
and that was keeping me from you know
flying in the in the sky and thinking
he's invisible so you have to remember
that your opponents are very good
and uh that
if you're a very confident guy like me
or mike tyson and then things will work
perfect levon well you're most likely
going to go into the last couple of
rounds as the co-leader unless wesley
pulls off a miracle today uh stay away
from the knockout and we'll see you in
uh tomorrow thank god guys back to you
thank you christian uh thank you lavon
always interesting uh interviews with
lavonne quoting that uh sage sage of our
days yeah though like mike nice to meet
you and along with the grand master
preparation there that very high level 2
800 i forgot i forgot i forgot
yeah just no this is very much
i i instantly remember the story uh
in my own personal practice there was
this uh
story i played uh when the monaco
tournaments were still going the melody
amber events yeah i played some kind of
an arty martial against peter lecko
uh without going into detail since we're
not going to be bringing up bringing it
up on the board i played a line which
was reasonably rare at the time and we
both were playing like peter leko was a
huge specialist in all of those
positions but we
so i thought was i
and i played some kind of a
strange little plan and he blitzed out
like the first 20 moves showing a very
uh unorthodox idea like he developed the
bishop to e6 and then voluntarily played
bishop e6 c8 to put it on b7 later
instantly comfortably equalized perhaps
even more i didn't react in any kind of
a proper fashion and lost in 25 news
with white
and after the game i said
how come you weren't entirely surprised
by what i did he looked at me very
strangely and i i i said why are you
looking to me like me like this he said
you played this against me in the blitz
three months ago or something
and i thought oh yeah
that actually makes some sense yeah that
did happen it did happen yeah that did
happen and uh
yeah so those those kinds of senior
moments they i wasn't even that senior
at the time but i was preparing for
future senior more moments
getting the training in uh so i could
relate to to live on you know saying no
i don't remember any of those games
you're quoting tonight
because we had a discussion and you're
welcome to join our discussion uh by by
uh sending us your tweet but because we
had the discussion about being a second
and weighing that friendship versus uh
opening preparation um
prior to his world championship match in
murano in 1981 with victor korchner
we're in luzon
and victor's getting this homeopathic
vitamin therapy
and we discover something very very very
nice in the queen's gambit decline
variation that anatoly karpov plays and
i wrote everything down and i showed it
to michael steen and michael was glowing
and his approval and
it appeared on the board it was like
magic it was absolutely fantastic i mean
there it is on the board and michael and
i were so enthusiastic like we've got
karpov we've got the soviet team we're
going to win this game
victor thought for like an hour and 15
minutes and played something completely
different from what we had and i said
well victor after and it was a draw so
victor why didn't you play our analysis
and he goes
oh i forgot
i
think acapulco
cliff diving i mean i was just like you
forgot
the one great idea we had for the world
championship match you're not permitted
to forget you can't forget victory it
was terrible it was
uh has that happened alejandro you
prepare your your charge so well and
you've got that you and it happens and
then
they forgot they forgot the analysis
they misplayed it a finger failure i
mean this happens all the time
i wish i could say it doesn't
but after coaching at all different
kinds of levels yeah it happens at every
level like every level yeah people
forget things consistently
how about ian today has he forgotten his
prep
how's he doing i think jan is just
remembering some stuff and adding some
spice this is an interesting game so far
the engines of course say it's a pawn
right but there is compensation and it's
not easy to play you can see the bishop
is coming back to c2 and attacking f5
for the moment this king is also a
little bit exposed it's not super happy
this diagonal is open nothing going on
for the moment but you can imagine in
later positions this king is not going
to be super safe so black needs to solve
these problems
he has good nights he has a good queen
he has a couple of rooks that's going to
be fine the rook is coming to a no
problem but what do you do about this
pawn you can't let white just take it
for free right you're not going to have
a good position after that because this
bishop is kind of running free so you
could play the move f4 it attacks this
knight on g3 you don't want to throw in
pawn takes f4 because it just opens the
g file sure for the queen so you want to
throw in the move bishop c2 this is
probably what the players are
calculating at the moment bishop c2
queen somewhere probably on g8 s3 also
possible by the way and now either
knight e4 or knight f5
and i think in both scenarios the rook
will come to e8 and we're gonna have a
mess on our hands this structure is
unstable the king is a little bit weak
white's king not so much but it does
have some tactical issues sometimes
these knights are nice but what do you
do with both of them only the knight on
e5 is playing the knight on c6 would
like a better square now that it's
controlled by the c3 uh pawn on d4 and
b4 it cannot access e5 itself because of
the other knight fascinating little
struggle and speaking of remembering the
guys that are probably trying to
remember
their theory
is the idea between richard rapport and
maxima sherlock graf who are probably
very well aware that this was topical
like 20 years ago and they are neither
of them are [ __ ] players and they're
just kind of winging it remembering a
little bit of this a little bit of that
because hundreds of games have been
played in this position including some
classics and they still each have spent
about 45 minutes to get to this position
so yeah it's a it's a very funny
spectacle of you know two extremely
strong players and inventing the bicycle
here
and uh they will get there
but
frame and all yeah you
yeah but there yeah it's a very very
well known type where yeah there have
been some uh some very uh
famous games being very strong players
but but also i think tabia is another
one that we should add to the list of
chess terms you're going to explain that
one
yeah tabia from the arabic was uh as a
starting position when chess was first
played it was a much much slower game
than it is today the pawns couldn't move
two squares the queen couldn't
rage all over the board and the idea was
that in the ancient game
they played very slowly and they had
these setups that they liked and they
became known as tabias opening
i would actually like some guidance on
this i'm not sure if
actually i should are we because i i've
always said i've always pronounced it
tabia but i have a sneaking suspicion
it's actually tabia i think you're right
too uh but i i can't force myself to
relearn it somewhere like i mean you've
got it it is it is so slow yes it's so
stuck in my mind exactly that i keep on
mispronouncing it but i'm pretty sure it
is
exactly by the way peter when we when
we're talking about the tabia
of the game between richard and mvl i
think you just said
bishop c5 bishop c you include okay yeah
i i basically uh and i think in my heart
to show off my knowledge
you forgot to include the move rook 81.
yeah okay one of course is a very
important conclusion here because you
are tickling the bishop you're just
winning a full tempo here because right
b7 is fairly unfairly forced yeah you
definitely don't want to drop a knight
in the way first of all you're hanging
this pawn with a check and other issues
so bishop e7 and only now and now you
take you go 96. and
but still after rook fc8 i believe the
current understanding is that black
holes here and usually you're not forced
to take on c5 i think the famous kramnik
sheriff game featured some kind of a
pawn march on the king so i think he
went for some sort of h3 followed by g4
plans
not bishop c5 i don't think you've been
played straight away i think you can
play h3 though i think this is what yeah
this is the kramnik share of game and
maybe even an earlier game by by karpov
i have a feeling maybe karpov won his
game against somebody and then should
have held against kramnik which is how
how it went it's a very reliable it's a
very sharp end game it's it's a very uh
imbalanced sharp end game where black
obviously has a very very nice structure
on the queen side exactly and uh i think
if you just look at the pawn structure
here you pick black because black made
more progress towards creating a passer
on the queen side sure but white has by
far the more active pieces and i think
in general black is the side fighting
for equality here but the quality should
be available if you play precisely yeah
but you kind of
like what you say it's three versus uh
two the majorities on both sides uh but
you got the two bishops i agree the
rooks are very very handsome but um
yeah well that's that that that's why it
became such a very topical line it's fun
stuff
this is a game that
people like to see
it could be an entertaining uh position
alejandro back
over to you and what uh has caught your
eye
um no i'm just following this game sure
okay well that's good we can go around
the horn a little bit let's see if
there's anything new uh nope still
thinking about after queen e2 bishop c2
and queen of two players
a little curiosity it was actually the
engine's top move tied with the move e4
there were a lot of lines to calculate
after e4 queen of two a little bit more
passive rep bears the advance it
prepares e4 again right
e4 because it takes takes and at the end
this battery is attacking f7 which is
probably why the engine wants to go
queen d7 you can see that arrow
defending the fight on f7
it also might prepare h4 and g5 which is
a firewall change of the structure as
well for white maybe even h4 knight g3
and g5 and then ask this knight where he
wants to go h4 knight f4 g5 with a
similar idea also targeting the pawn on
d5 so a more multi-purpose move than the
direct e4 it's hard to say which one is
stronger there's different ways of
handling the position i like this one it
keeps up two ideas at the same time
challenges um linear to find a move
notice that his last move was the move
b5 if you want to follow up with a5 as i
mentioned earlier when the pawn is on a5
i can't take this pawn because rook bait
runs into a4 and you can't actually move
the knight from b5 it doesn't mean that
this is losing or anything like that you
lose a pawn you sacrifice it and you
have some compensation but i don't know
if it's enough queen f2 played a little
bit more of a kg move also like it
because it makes linear think this is
always a good thing to do in your games
uh thank you for that alejandro and uh
once again a reminder peter uh of our
upcoming schedule yeah the schedule is
straightforward but then the the next
bit of info is potentially very
interesting we have three rounds left
one today uh one tomorrow and then uh on
saturday we will conclude proceedings
with round nine but that that the small
prince at the bottom there this is the
playoff scenario if two players are tied
for first they shall contest a rapid
round robin
uh well that's not around robin really
that's a match right uh you you start
with game uh
15 plus 10 15 plus 10 rapid game if
three or more players uh they will
actually play rapid round robin right
right but
because of time concerns they will play
a 10 plus five
[Music]
it's either a very fast rapid or very
slow bleed i think it's probably still
still a very uh very fast rapid and if
it's still a tie after all that
uh there will be a single armageddon
game no blitz portion whatsoever you
just go straight to armageddon uh five
minutes for white four minutes for black
and black obviously gets rods uh i'm
assuming if the graphic doesn't mention
uh increment from move 61 don't there's
anything yeah but
we would like some clarification if you
could uh if you could uh check this for
us because i think in in case of
armageddon this is still very far away
but these days it's a very well very
kind of an important question in terms
of uh what this armageddon looks like
because five against four with no
increment whatsoever is a very difficult
different game to five against four big
differences with let's say one second
increment from move 61. i love
uh the playoffs um
to determine the champions uh
i think that that's great i hate the
mathematical formula um i was very very
happy i'd like to get your thoughts uh
that fide made the candidates tournament
also a playoff previously
it only had these tie breaks and they
were a little bit arcane and um some
people were unhappy maybe vladimir
kramny was uh kramnik was unhappy in
2013 when
when he
lost the tiebreaker
mathematically i think
like from from any kind of a viewpoint
if we want to develop chess as a
spectator sport if we want to attract
more more viewership if we want to uh
promote chess properly i think the idea
that the two players finish on the same
score and then you know we consult some
kind of a you know zonneberg burger and
they have to explain to the viewing
audience what is
and generally you want in particular
when it's something important at stake
you want that to be decided
over the board exactly yeah and uh i
understand that you know classical time
control purists perhaps uh you know
fields
if the if the entire cycle is classical
and then a very important part of the
cycle is decided in short time controls
i've heard those objections and i sort
of understand where they're coming from
but i still feel it's infinitely
preferable
to just you know taking out your excel
spreadsheets
and like
your your draw
in round three against somebody who is
having a bad event is somehow you know
making you not qualify for the title
match doesn't doesn't feel right
yeah and uh
more and more different uh playoff
scenarios as well where in norway for
example they have armageddons to
determine uh the the point splitting in
case of a draw yeah there's the a lot of
thought has gone uh into uh solving this
this problem uh in recent years and
one thing i really really like is the
the fact that
you know all the ideas that were
basically talking points but nobody was
brave enough to actually try and
implement them and see how they work are
now getting a trial run for instance
like the america's cup
uh that just concluded here
which featured uh double limb
for the first time in like at least for
the first time in top tournament
practice in chess i was very very happy
about that because it felt to me that
at the very least we need to see how it
works with chess and i would assume it
works quite well because it works quite
well for all kinds of other games and i
don't see why it wouldn't work for chess
so i thought and i think we have to
credit alejandro there who is standing
there pretending he doesn't he doesn't
listen to me say these things but i
think he was one of the people who was
very seriously advocating for it with
yeah you know
and i remember uh alexander halifan back
in the days of las vegas and the world
cup advocating for a double round double
elimination pardon me and it worked
really really good for the i think it's
a very natural feat it produces
audience it produces more action and
produces more things more things to
discuss there is more intrigue yeah and
also you know compared to to a single
knockout uh
single knockout two
two game mini matches are
extremely harsh they really extremely
yeah and and uh giving the field a
second chance feels like it's a it's a
good idea in general so yeah i'm i was
very uh very excited to see that this
finally gets a trial run
and i'm hoping we will see more of that
in the future good uh turning our
attention back to chess for a moment ali
reza just played this move queen f2 and
more i've just kind of gotten a chance
to
zan into it i like it i like it a lot
actually uh
white is prepping h3e4 he's also
you know on a good day you know
alejandro has been pointing out that
knight takes b5 as a nibble you don't
want to lose the pawn on b2 maybe the
queen on f2 with the knight coming to g3
actually does something yeah and
i've been i've been watching alejandra
talk about this position and i did
notice that it was very curious to me
that a5 knight b5 if we continue down
that that road a5 knight to xb5 from
the temptation to just stop here and say
we're upon up i think it's quite strong
but i didn't notice that the engines
were i think giving black a slight edge
of the night before yep
i don't i don't know if black is
actually better but the fact that the
engines just don't hate it at all like
it's remarkable this much is clear that
at the very least you can state that the
engine doesn't dislike this
is is quite curious because the knight
mp5 will be very difficult to challenge
uh in general i think we're just playing
uh
please keep it there it's not supporting
e34 anymore uh you probably have to
abandon uh the ideas of at least an
immediate attack in the center you have
to deal with the threat of knight d3 you
might have to make an incredibly ugly
move knight c1
i don't know if it's forced but it
definitely is one of the candidates here
because allowing 93 looks ugly right but
knight c1 also doesn't look like like
it's not terrible yeah and black i guess
just plays on queen g7 and continues
quietly but that but that's the type of
thing where i think as a human player
certainly as a grand master you go
oops a three a four
end of story i'm not analyzing any
further and the fact that the computer
has nothing else to do with its
teraflops but to go no it's okay night
before that is remarkable and also the
reason i bring this up is that a5 is
probably the most forceful way to
preempt the white advances in the center
because we do have to deal with it it is
the idea of eventually eventually is it
something like if we go queen d7 yes
okay
protecting the pawn on f7 i mean i don't
know
no it doesn't it shouldn't work right
it's still not the end of story though i
can imagine crazy ideas like g5 or
something yeah i don't know
uh but queen d7 and you're
you know you you don't have to play a5
and b4 or you could do it slowly three
maybe knight g3
okay i'm assuming i'm playing more like
a human player now
uh
can i h4 or
h4 is one idea that honda also mentioned
i'm i keep on trying to push a 3 4
without any further ado but i think the
issue is you will take only four
yeah and if i go like knight takes i
think my g knight c4 95 i just hate
i think 95 just stabilizes so well
that's why you want yeah i think i have
to take with the other one to at least
try to prevent you from getting the 95
move in okay
but you take only four i guess and then
bishop g7 and
i did blend the bishop takes h6 though
if you play bishop j7 so i mean
we saw that daniel dayak uh against i
mean
when he played the move bishop takes a3
remember when daniel played that move it
was a little bit of a shock yeah
it was like i wasn't looking at knight
d5 to c3 and uh uh here bishop takes h6
as a [ __ ]
but i feel like i'm trying to force some
things here
i'm demanding more of white's position
than there is maybe there's there
exactly yeah and 27 by the way uh played
by le lanier so
we will see what elreza feels uh feels
about all of these things
uh something to be said for
h4 g5 right away
yes but
like without knight g3 black will just
okay
let's let's try let's try and put an
idea on the board so i'm going to play
h4 so the idea is let's just put another
move you could play rook b8 as well
something like this and here i it's very
self-evident what i'm i'm playing for i
want to play g5 and
gift me the ball
yeah which is why black needs to be much
faster obviously bishop g7 is uh
kind of a non-move here you need to you
need to be doing something much more
proactive okay i'm not sure exactly what
uh i mean rook b8 yeah let's go rugby a
b8 let's go to bh let's drop in and see
how
how fast is the move b5 b4
you wear here is time for b4 or you
don't yeah i i kind of hate it without
a5 but maybe you have to you know before
a before knight takes exactly the
problem i'm having with a5 is this g5 is
coming super super fast and
again i mean i'm hating on losing a pawn
maybe the computer says it's not so bad
uh keep playing takes takes knight h7
but b4 a b knight b4
um
knee-jerk thoughts here peter are you i
think i go bishop c1
it's much easier for me to make a move
here than to assess what's happening i
think bishop c1 is a very clever move
here because i think we need to be more
prepared for knight g3 and we absolutely
need to keep the ball on uh b2
covered so that we don't blunder it in
the future
one of the drones i have no idea how to
assess this position one of the
drawbacks for me of the move bishop uh
is that now with the knight on b4
bishop d6 is
offending yeah sure but if like if we
play g4 g5 which is sort of continuing
along the same path exactly take stakes
knight h7 the pawn might just drop you
know queen of five might be coming very
quickly here
it's still not the end of the story
absolutely
i do have a trick i do have a trickies
knight takes uh
like game continues even here right i go
yeah the four knight g2 rook takes b2
who knows what that is
it's a mess everywhere we look and again
at the end of the day the rook will
actually be
doing something on b2 okay that's fun uh
we'll definitely keep an eye on this one
and uh definitely of the the sharpest
position we have so far
despite the fact that for instance the
nippon nishi uh mamijarov game features
a very just balanced position with the
black uh opponent and by the way bishop
c2
c6 which i saw on alejandro's screen
it's a very uh in like the point is he
will play knight e7 now after bishop c2
and white will not have queen b5
wow
that's a concept i mean uh okay you know
what we do it it oftentimes happens that
we're on set and uh we have a position
like this and alejandra says something
like well you know there's a serious
threat in the position and and i go what
is that and alejandro says my serious
threat is i'm going to play the move
bishop c2 and the pawn on f5 is just
falling and your game's terrible say
well let me show the audience i'm going
to make a passing move a bad move
and then he plays a7 a6 bishop c2 knight
e7 and you immediately spotted
uh the positive uh
uh yeah
is actually quite quite important for us
it would attack quite a lot of things
along with your frank and also the b7.0
exactly maybe less important but still a
queen hitting the e5
and but i sort of came prepared because
i did see that uh there was a second
suggestion after a phobicity queen g8 on
the hundred screen uh if i
i mean i i sensing a weakness i'm gonna
double up
i guess i i guess i can also double up
right i can go rook f7 okay for okay f8
and
we kind of reach parity on on the
attacks and defense on the f5 square and
eventually maybe i will play queen
you just get your queen off of that i
don't have a good square though like i i
wanted to say i will play queen e6 and
then i realize this will blunder and
exchange the bishop b3
i mean i don't know about the parody
because i can definitely put more
pressure on the pawn on f5 then maybe
you can yeah maybe g5 g4 in one of these
positions
okay
major blink
yes
uh-huh g5 g4 okay definitely that's by
the way rook f2 on the board don't blink
being
don't blink one of the
all-time yeah a3 is
still a move that has been played but
one of the rare ones here after rook fc8
a2 a3 i think
showing to a degree the fact that maybe
richie himself is not as familiar with
this position as
uh as you would have expected this being
you know still a very very heavily
trodden
you know theoretical ground because i
don't think b5 before at least until
black played rook a b8 b5 before isn't
as much of a threat because after knight
a4 you have to go to uh squares you
perhaps don't particularly want to
occupy due to the knight b6 ideas
because you've been mentioning that
there's been so many games from this
specific position i gotta ask the
question do you know what would happen
after rookie five there's something
i find attractive about rookie five if i
think i just go i just i think i just go
bishop
yeah that was my point was that i was
thinking that i could try to sneak my
rook over to g5 when all your pieces
might be huddled on the queen side
blundering wondering the pawn is how can
my pawn not be on h3 how dare that be
the case
bishop f2 king f2 knight g4 check don't
play rookie fight that was the point i
wanted possibly one of the ideas of h2h3
which is actually the major major move
in this position
so it's the most most often played the
move move in this mission is actually
very prepping but i think mainly mainly
with the idea of g4 because mainly
i think if we if we delve slightly
deeper into this position the knight on
f6 is the reason black pollution doesn't
fall apart because rook d7 never happens
right right so you want to play h3 g4 g5
and get the g7 square for your g1 rook
and if that happens makes sense you make
tremendous amounts of progress so h3 is
right away
is played i think very specifically with
the idea of following it up as g4 okay
and uh
yeah black needs to be black needs to be
precise and i i will not claim i i know
exactly how to equalize after it brings
me to the question of a28 a3 because
that has nothing to do with h2h3 and
driving the night away
it's a prophylactical moving against
black's potential counterplay on the
queen side and you very often with with
your knight on c3 these days and all
kinds of structures you see players
spend spend the tempo on a2a3 just to
secure the knight on c3 so that it
cannot easily be chased away
but in this particular position it feels
like probably just
slightly a waste of a tempo giving black
feels like it though giving black time
to uh to consolidate and uh do something
proactive i'm not even sure like even if
you give black a temper here i'm not
quite sure what the plan is
engines really like playing rook ab8 but
what threat does that create i still
don't know perhaps it just simply you
know improves your position here h3 you
go bishop b6 now bishop a7 and then
bishop c6
uh if g4 you play bishop c6 and you once
again
reacquire control over the g7 square
you can imagine
some positions in which you know black
could uh start thinking maybe i uh i've
got the two bishops i've got some action
going on in my favor
fascinating position we'll definitely
keep
an eye on this um alejandra going to
turn it over to you uh
wesley so
daniel either player making any uh
any player making contact don't head
over to me head over to the players we
might have a handshake coming up pretty
soon because the
vacuum has come to the board taking off
all all the rooks off
i don't imagine the black has absolutely
anything white definitely does have
nothing in this position oh boy i mean
the knight is attacking the queen the
queen could go to b6 i think bb6 is by
far the most natural move and it also
very much invites knight c4 i mean it's
nice before i don't think anybody like
is thinking about a win in this position
so queen b6 is my expectation knight c4
yeah i wonder why knight d6 wasn't
played instead i mean that's that's the
one attempt i would have instead of
knight a5 is 96 not a move at all
after queen b7 the question uh peter is
asking is
knight d6 obviously if you put the queen
on the c file then you've got some
actual tricky ideas yeah that was my
idea but the h3 is completely fine this
is what i
i forgot with the pawns on h3 yeah with
the power on h2 you can go h2 takes g3
after knight e7 27 king of age and you
have to spoil your structure with fx g
why this still not really wars i suspect
with the bishop against knight kind of
an end game but you were you're right it
wasn't what you wanted yeah you are
happy with playing you use this once you
know yeah i i i don't like spoiling the
double pawns there but uh
that probably is just it you you spotted
it right away that knight d6
is meant by queen to c7 and again no i
thought knight of five was clever and
then i realized specifically because we
have already played h3 the entire line
makes no particular sense yeah that's
that's how you eventually lose a
position which you never ever should
lose exactly okay so that game may very
well be heading towards a handshake and
queen d7 in the ali
raza
position
and here there's two very different
approaches i think that's intriguing
that one approach is h4 g5 and other
approaches h3 knight g3 for slow slow
slow should i say linear has more time
than elereza
that is what yes
otherwise has been tanking since he got
out of the opening he's played every
pinch very slowly what is that
what lanier has more time holy smoke
well it has to do with the 11 minute
thing that la ressa has been on in this
particular moment considering his
options stop the press wow
okay but what i wanted to say is two
very different approaches a slow
approach h3 knight g3 bishop f1 e4 you
you you get to do everything and you do
it on your own uh time line knight g3
bishop oops got that that's sorry that
bishop seems way too slow though in the
face of rook b8 a5 before this looks way
too slow like a5b4 might be coming far
too fast and then contrarily there's a
completely different approach which is
to go h4
g5 drop your knight in on i4 and target
the pawn on d5 two very different
approaches uh peter jump in
and well straight into the repetition uh
wesley so and booked on there perhaps
now we can really
show those players well
as bogdan is really deciding if he wants
to go knight a5
and force to draw but i think the time
to look for an advantage is is long gone
yeah earlier yeah
definitely
yeah i mean
nobody really likes uh kind of admitting
that
the entire game has been excellent you
know exercise and futility but by this
point you you're not really pushing
pushing uh
yeah well especially with four rooks off
the board the idea is to make the pawn
on a7 a6 a potential weakness
and it's not weak anymore the rooks are
not lined up against it
uh
it's gone no advantage again uh peter
you're you're ducking the question not
really i kind of no i'm kind of holding
i've already sort of nailed my colors to
the mask here i don't think i don't
think slow play gets there for white i
think okay you are very much on the
clock because if black lens this gun to
play with b4 in particular if black has
time enough to play five and before
comfortably
you just you're just going to dislike
your position immensely with instantly
yeah and
instantly the knight on c3 is so
important to to to uh bolster
the e3 e4 event so we are on h4 and
let's say we do something something h4
related seems seems to be called for
yeah and we've tried rook b8 and i like
the united four idea i think all the
things we we've seen so far i liked
united four idea quite a bit i
more or less we're kind of repeating
what we previously did uh
i went for
b5b4 because i feared yeah giving up
giving up the central pawn is uh
disaster seems very uh very risky i mean
there is
an argument for let me try something
please a5
a5 g5 yes yeah and i want to play b4
here
okay without even taking on g5 i think i
want as many pawns alive as possible on
the king's side
um i suspect this will not work out but
like gfb takes c3 i don't know if you
want to include the aba b probably not i
don't know bishop take c3 i assume
that could be a reason i i lack a good
move here my my issue is i would like to
chase away the knight from a four and
play queen five and pick up the ball on
f6 sounds and then i think it will be
tremendous for black but the issue is
bishop d6 is still unplayable because of
simply knight takes d5 and after queen
f5 i am still not threatening anything
apart from bishop d6
um but maybe this is not unplayed like
bishop six is a serious threat though
exactly
exactly
so that was that was a curious idea i
had which
well especially i'm beginning to have uh
annoyances let's put it that way that my
pawn on e3 is
under uh duress i could have back here i
could have played pardon me i will take
now take a look at yeah a b a b a b a b
i'll take this yeah okay you'll take
this fella i'll take this fellow okay i
would never probably still need to play
queen f5 though you want to play a3 e4
somewhere that's exactly it but even
those positions are not that clear
actually i will take twice i'll take
with the rook and
i mean i wouldn't be surprised if black
is busted but i also wouldn't be
surprised if it turned out to be
playable uh i was playing for e i even
i i'm kind of waiting for you this no
i need to play bishop v6 here so oh
sorry sorry the pawn you're right yeah i
need to play bishop to six and then once
again
i
if it turns out this just doesn't work
move by move
i will i will be more shocked
in the slightest but i don't see it just
yet i i think
i think this is an unclear position
which which could turn out to be uh
playable for black but it's difficult to
kind of force yourself to play like this
and reza made a move that we haven't
really considered but which is also kind
of logical i think he played the movie
queen f two g two two
oh wow
improving the position of the queen
uh we'll just show uh
what they did uh through the magic of
television
we get an instant replay what they did
through the magic of television is they
called an arbiter and
told the arbiter if i play queen b7
i'm gonna draw uh okay
queen g2
yeah instead of h4 actually okay i'll
take that one back instead of h4
straight away
and they're
uh
for uh daniel
50
at uh
the round seven mark he would have
signed up for that right away i think i
think
it's it's a bit of a letdown considering
that he was in the lead and he lost this
very very dramatic game to linear
yesterday yes which at the certain point
he was doing quite well in general even
linear was very complimentary about his
play in the first half of the game and
said he was he felt getting outplayed
but right but then in severe time
trouble in years experience and both of
them are very experienced because they
seem to be in severe time trouble in
every game but right here is just older
so he has he's done this for longer
right
so
the old hand of experience does count
for something after all right yeah queen
g i think the point is he wants to go e4
straight away i think currently like if
you play rook a b8 okay i think it's
possible to go e4
because there's some tempo against the
the rook after e4 no simply fee no
simply f yeah and the knight is hanging
on f6 right of course it is takes g4h3 i
i caught it it has no squares right
so this appears to be working out for
white tactically yes
so pinch two is a very concrete move
actually aimed aimed at simply pushing
our one big idea like strategically
three four is one of the biggest ideas
in all of these structures totally we
have recreated the threat of e4 e3 e4
there's a number of ways of dealing with
it like one way would be to support the
knight on f6 by something like bishop g7
so that if if you continue along the
same path i can take one d4 for instance
here right because f6 is no longer
hanging
that's a channel it's uh yeah this looks
horrible so afterwards g7 we probably go
back to ideas of h4 but the inclusion of
mg2 in bishop g7 i would suspect is
maybe in white's favor because maybe we
get more pressure against the g5 pawn
later yeah it also stops these ideas
that you've been demonstrating with the
bishop once i get my knight to f4 the
bishop d6 can be very
annoying
um including as you say putting
tricking luring baiting uh the bishop to
g7 so that uh and no longer could go to
d6 and attack my knight
i
i like it queen g2 looks uh
the more you look at it it it becomes
attractive yeah it's so it's a logical
move it still is a very very sharp
position which
we requires precise play as we've been
trying ourselves uh to
make these precision moves uh
let's keep this and uh on the back
burner for just a moment because i'm
curious to how the game between uh
ritchie and mvl is unfolding uh much as
you suggested after the movie okay
played in kb8 and guess what
h2h3 you kind of need this yeah because
your your plans on the king side very
much hinge on being able to play g3 g4
otherwise you you can't you can
challenge knight on f6 without offering
mass trades while let's say 94 or before
yeah and then uh actually i'm being told
that h3 was a novelty but after bishop
v6 we're back in familia territory okay
transposition yeah and that's happened
maybe once or twice already earlier that
they transposed uh from a queen's gambit
accepted into a moran actually the
interesting about this thing about this
game is gonna have three novelties in
one
it's actually very unusual right but
it's three levels in one game yeah h3
has never been played before in this
specific position after rugby
first time h3 has ever been played i
believe back here we had a novelty
somewhere around here c5 knight c3 b5 e4
bishop b7 yeah bishop b7 had never been
played before specifically in this
position and
they will at some point have to deviate
from the five games that we have in the
database so three novelties in one
single game that's actually almost never
happens uh let's go to bucharest as
christian has with him wesley saw the
leader of the tournament
thank you alejandra wesley quite an
uneventful uh draw today how did you
approach this match against bogdan
daniel deck with the black pieces oh
well first i want to say many good
things about my opponent i think he he's
a very strong player he's very young
he's only 20. i think he's still got a
lot of potential to improve
uh so he's clearly the number one player
in romania right now uh
yesterday he was also better and if he
won that game with black he would have
called it torment with us
so um
i
i think he's doing something special in
this tournament also last year but
especially this
and fortunately for me he played long
game yesterday so i thought he won't
have as much energy today
and
he's
hyper focused i think my mom likes him a
lot as a player
so he's got
very he's very focused he knows his
lines he knows his openings
but i noticed he doesn't have a very
good
reply against the queen's gambit
accepted which is what maxim butcher
lagrava has been doing this tournament
so i thought i'd give it a try
also to avoid any specific preparation
by the axe so let's get straight into it
yeah the queen's gamut accepted how did
you uh
come up to uh this conclusion that you
should probably go for this line
uh well first of all maxim played this
against me with black a few days ago so
i thought i'd ride in the other side and
there are other openings like thrills to
play the king's indian the other day
against the act but didn't really go
well
i mean i could play my normal stuff but
for sure he would have something
prepared there
so
i thought i'd give it but also lanier
has been playing
this
queen's game accepted against me nonstop
so i thought
why not use it for the other caller and
he played b3 also without revealing too
much you did mention that you uh
analyzed his games and he tried to
understand his style what would you say
are the positions that he doesn't feel
comfortable in your opinion of course uh
uh well i
only look at briefly from this game so i
don't really know him well but as i said
i think he's still got a lot of
potential to improve but it seems like
in some
positions some new new interesting
positions
which he hasn't seen like which he
hasn't prepared he sometimes feels very
uncomfortable
and
also in maneuvering positions he usually
loses his weight
also in this tournament he's got very
poor time management which
uh
didn't allow him to score more
and uh
um
he's a very solid very stable player
but uh it's not as
aggressive as others
let's get back into the game and you did
try to keep
the game quite compact that's fine i i
this was the exact line i played against
maximi with with white
if you remember
okay so so bishop s3 maxim played queen
d7 which is
which is slightly worse after rook c4
it did feel like you got some pressure
if i remember correctly in that game
with the white even at the end you had
some options to get out of the
repetition
yeah because he made a mistake but
uh it was pretty equal because i didn't
play accurate in the opening but uh yeah
he also made some inaccuracies like him
but there was some some improvements
yeah i think bishop f3 so bishop takes
f3 is correct because group a7 loses the
knight b5 okay no i didn't mix up my
preparation
the black's main problem here obviously
is the knight on b8 which cannot move
but other than that it's uh pretty
stable
but yeah i think i played all the best
moves so far i don't
recall
analyzing more than this
but um
so at this point you were still somehow
within your knowledge and preparation
yeah i think until like 27 for some
reason but i mean white has many other
more critical lines in the queen's
gambit accepted so i wasn't exactly sure
if the ark would go but i think he
wanted to play solidly today because
also he lost because of yesterday's loss
yeah i i think uh yeah queen this
yeah sorry i mean i thought about rook
b8 here but i guess it's just much
simpler to trade everything and i
thought he could take
maybe this end game is
slightly worse for black
like king f1 g4
ps1 i guess g4 or king e2
but i guess i i might have some problems
with the g7 pawn but
the computer doesn't see it so
yeah and
i mean
once all the heavy
pieces are created black's defense is
quite easy and here queen v7
was accurate although
yes pretty i the funny part is that i
was calculating here knight b6 queen c7
unfortunately bishop a3 doesn't win
i have one so you have only this square
for the queen yeah g5 very nice and
after f4 i think i also only have oh i
have two squares we have queen a5 and
queen h5 yeah that's that's really
pretty yeah so that's the only line i
had to calculate to make sure everything
works but when we say it's good because
if we go here
might run into some problems
yeah some problems here
wesley you're going into the last fresh
the last couple of games as the
co-leader of the event alongside
leveroni and tomorrow you're facing ali
reza with the white pieces what is your
experience if any with alireza
um
let's see i think i only played him once
in classical chess before no i can't say
more 25 years ago then i played him some
i played love rapped against him online
also the granchester in paris but that's
about it i mean he's
i don't really know him very well he's
very young he's
clearly very talented very strong i mean
he can't reach
number three in the world
without talent absolutely by the same
time he's only a teenager so we'll see
what he wants to do with his life if he
wants to really focus on chess but i
mean
considering the tournament i
feel like just want to play my best
chess like that's my goal before the
tournament and that should be what my
goal now and not think too much about
the
standings and ourselves i mean levon won
two games with black but i also wanna
technically draw an end game against ian
so
i
it is very useful i think
you know players are getting a bit tired
here in the last stretch
but at the same time we should just try
to play some good chess see what happens
thank you wisely go get your rest and
we'll see you tomorrow thank you guys
back to you thank you christian thank
you wesley and let's take a look at our
current standings
with uh two games in the history books
peter yeah and uh
this is uh the players who have already
finished their games uh today the top
four
two draws
made made draws against each other and
the rest of the field is still playing
there will be a tie of between the same
two players at the top nobody can reach
them yet but some people could get the
plus one
with
victories in their games
one person who is definitely determined
to try to get to plus one is ian versus
shaq uh
what do you have for us alejandro that
game precisely us we have some updates
we left it off with the move 97
defending the spawner f5 a very logical
retreat and you guys
said why don't i double up on the f file
and you guys answered it well because
black can as well so they did that rook
after rook have seven rook f1 rook fade
when bishop b3 was played this is a very
nice move the bishop came back to c2
after the rooks determined their
position on the file why because the
rook is actually uncomfortably placed it
has to go to f6 if it goes to g7 it's
met also with knight h5 but on g7 it's
actually caught
on f6 it can at least go on the sixth
round the engines really preferred rook
c6 very inhuman move this is an open
file i like putting rooks on open files
rook d6 was played and the engines were
screaming for the move c4
it shuts the bishop out temporarily but
c5 is the threat and also queen b2 is a
threat in many positions taking
advantage of this weakened diagonal we
had talked about earlier yes your knight
on h5 is currently hanging because the
queen is the only defender but there are
ways to fix this g4 will work sometimes
sometimes queen b2 is enough of a threat
that you can let the knight on h5 go
because of the remaining pins down the
line the engines eventually thought
white was better in this position after
changing their mind a few times
specifically with the move rook d3 which
i find very inhuman because it just
invites bishop c2 it doesn't find
another way of defending though instead
after the move rook f6985 rook d6
yen immediately put the pawn on g4 which
i also think is a testing move it
immediately puts pressure on this button
f5 and it's asking later on c4 queen b2
will be an idea how are you going to
develop here with black pieces and i
think it's not such an easy problem to
solve here for shock the engines are
giving a few options in which this can
be good but they're a little scary for
example 93 can be played same idea
attack the rook on rook g2 the engines
are just very weirdly going back saying
look i've discoordinated your rooks now
it's time to go back with the knight but
it's also possible to just play c4
sacrifice this exchange remember that
queen b2 is going to be stronger when
this knight is on h5 as it covers the g7
and f6 squares don't forget about c5
opening up that bishop later so g4 is
currently on the board testing shock to
find a way to defend his position he's
currently up upon remember that and his
pieces don't look too bad
but and we have a rook sighting where's
the road going that was the question
where is a rook can't go to d3 can it
peter
i'm not entirely sure yeah that's uh
he was reaching for the road he
definitely was reaching for the rookie
yeah and i was briefly sort of startled
by the
uh the and here it goes
and he was still uncertain he was
keeping his hand
you know tethered to the rook there he
didn't plant it with authority uh
that looks all together wrong to my uh
eyes uh
yeah how bad it is
is it bad it's
not terrible according to the engine you
do have to kick out the rook i mean sure
that part makes sense bishop c2 attacks
the rook not entirely sure where he
wants to move it he's going to take the
pawn let's put it on
d8 i thought he's going to take the pawn
on c3 maybe oh
i mean you know like oh he put the rook
i didn't put the rook there peter you
backed me up on this one yeah that would
be the bond come on you know you have to
assume this is the idea and the fact
that the engine doesn't think it works
doesn't make it the idea i'm pretty sure
this is still what he is intending i
don't know 63
bishop f5 software the thing is opening
up this diagonal right it's so
counterintuitive too dangerous i
understand what you're saying the angel
says queen d2 which is very strong in
this position i don't care about queen
d2 as a human
why is why is this not just good well do
i have to take on f5
no that's maybe not maybe true we should
be good we need queen b6 to hit e3 queen
b6 to hit e3
whoa this is very cool the bishop bishop
e4 is dangerous clear but bishop b6 is
winning
you just got mated there's a tornado on
the f8 yeah it takes and damn
yep that's that's pretty much made you
just don't have enough defenders on this
side of the board you put a rook on c3
and the queen on v6 and the engine find
found a way to kill you no
i as a human would be afraid of bishop
maybe if i don't see bishops sure from
far away i'll be
worried about simply bishop before takes
something takes and problems down on the
file so i would be a little bit scared
of that
i'm very surprised about the move for d3
i'm not gonna lie i would never look at
this pawn on c3 and be like yeah this is
the one i really want to munch i i i
wouldn't want to invite bishop c2 bishop
takes f5 myself the move rook the e3
really uh is uh awakening uh we have
folks uh who want to join our discussion
peter let's do that yeah
uh
dennis boris hi dan hi hi dennis yeah
should there be more rapid than blitz
events or the hell's practice all day
all the upcoming tiebreaks
any thoughts well we have a in the grand
chess tour itself we do have uh a number
of rapid blitz only events ones coming
up warsaw one's coming out here in st
louis yeah i assume it's not a question
about the composition of the tour
because
of the store or yeah more rapid than
blitz in general
i think yeah i i mean
the simple answer would seem would just
be yes i think
well-organized events we're sure the
time controls attract you know they're
fun to play in uh they they attract
viewership because they're fun to watch
there's always something going on and
yes these days there's as dennis points
out there's an additional
value in in playing shorter time
controls because you are
expecting
yeah uh that at some point in your life
your your skills and rapid employees
will actually decide
uh some things
and play in in classical yeah uh so yeah
the simple answer is yes but then you
you come to the kind of the boring
question of logistics and you know
finding sponsorship and
that's probably not the theme that needs
to be discussed right now but
uh
if if we could
i'm all in favor of more chess in
general and more rapid chess uh
definitely for for me i
absolutely i'd love to see more bliss
tournaments i i'm really really pleased
i want to put it that way that now we
have an annual world bliss championship
for for many decades uh we would have
maybe one great blitz event every eight
years or so now we have an annual but
i'd love to see for example a
continental blitz championship whether
it be europe north america
i think
this championship exists yeah rapid and
blitz exists yeah don't stop watching
america yeah i would love to see more
blitz uh events as well so the answer is
yes and especially because now playoffs
yeah it's becoming uh very topical i
mean i mean it's it's very definitely
self-sustainable i mean it doesn't have
to train you for anything it's just it's
just fun and uh
and interesting and very and very good
for for spectators which is something
that we need to a question for you did
you always i mean everybody has their
own fancy of themselves as to like
they think of themselves as a better
classical player a better rapid player
or a better blitz player how did you
feel about yourself and your career you
i mean these days i definitely am a
a better shorter time control player
than i am classical i don't play enough
classical and uh
my uh
like i would need to start restart my
work on openings yeah to sort of become
a competitive classical player but i i
still am reasonably okay at shorter time
controls because i can add leave much
much easier there alejandro jump right
in how do you fancy yourself that you
were a better rapid player blitz player
classical player i mean my blitz rating
is like 130 points higher than my
classical or rapid
answered i guess peter decided that
blitz is where i'm i'm good at uh don't
cubby-hole yourself
for me the acceptance of rapid is not
just about acceptance at the top i would
like to see
rapid especially rapid ratings be more
normalized among lower rated players
because i feel so many tournaments are
becoming inaccessible for players i
remember having to travel for my norms
having to travel for so many events that
when you think about it amateurs just
can't go to uh so many players i've met
specifically
in america think oh i would love to play
capella ground i would love to play
arrow flood open i would love to play
gibraltar reykjavik but then they see
the schedule and they're like i can't
take
10 days off work this is my one vacation
a year i'm not gonna spend it playing
chess the entirety of it uh how about no
and
well it ends up alienating a lot of
people that i think would be more
willing to travel to tournaments more
willing to play in events if they were
shorter yep and the only way to do it
for in a shorter schedule is rapid
rapping and blitz
could say better myself
all very fair points we're going to take
a break we're going to see you on the
other side of our break see you then
[Music]
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
[Music]
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open
doors where people and machines are in
tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
and active communities
it sounds like life
and it's what you hear
when you really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
ascension
founded in 1839 the university of
missouri is steeped in tradition the
recently founded mizzou chess program is
a partnership between the university of
missouri and the st louis chess club
collegiate jess has been experiencing a
meteoric rise at the national level
through its tradition of excellence
mizzou has always strived for the best
mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institutions
ethos of respect responsibility
discovery and excellence to the
chessboard
[Music]
a st louis public radio journalists most
precious possession isn't a notepad
camera
microphone or recording device their
most precious possession
is credibility
a journalist's work revolves around the
truth
finding it
verifying it
and reporting it
great journalists work hard to find the
facts and put those facts into context
examining all the arguments and
including differing opinions
amplifying fascinating voices from our
community
telling captivating stories
offering facts that may have been
omitted
we work every day to earn your trust for
news turn to st louis public radio
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to our coverage of round
seven of bucharest super bed chess
classic and yeah the playing hall is
emptier than it was when the round
started but there are still three games
running and all three are exciting quite
exciting in their own special way
we've had two draws of the players at
the top yeah uh the the yeah the players
up top you see all drew against each
other wesley drew against bogdan dayak
and uh
caruana and aryan played a somewhat
uneventful
bishop's opening game which was also
drawn quite quickly actually was the
first one to be drawn
but the other three games are still very
much
in in fighting shape and we will be
watching them
well let's jump right in and it's it's
actually been a very fun game between uh
richie and mvl because up to this moment
uh something very rare has happened
we've had two
novelties but that should be three yeah
and then we did get the third novelty
right here king f1 apparently this
position has been reached before king f1
is a new idea and we immediately see
what richie had in mind by moving his
king to f1 i think he played the move f4
i think there was a specific also
tactical reason a bit earlier if you
play instead of king f1 if you play g5
here
which i'm not entirely sure but i have a
feeling bishop c8 maybe was intended
okay and if you play rook d6 here
not knight g7 but rook d6 yeah i think
i'm okay i thought maybe the idea is to
play the bishop c5 for bishop c7 but i
now realize rook c6 still exists so my
my entire spiel maybe is just incorrect
i thought the point was to protect the
rook on e1 so that a move like this
would just be completely unplayable
because knight takes e5 would exist
exactly so the rook would so protect
your room but maybe maybe
one maybe i'm overthinking things
but unbeating the f2 pawn and protecting
the recon in one are both very uh
valuable things for white and f2f4 here
clearly he is preparing to meet rook b8
with a 4f5 supporting the knight on e6
because if the knight if that actually
gets chased away black immediately
stands really really well there'll be a
lot of trades of rooks and these bishops
actually make a very nice impression but
like you said uh the move f4 f5 cements
the knight on e6 and yeah well i mean on
a good day i can follow it up maybe with
rook i still feel that black is
completely fine in particular i very
much like the move uh h7 h6 here just to
stop g4 g5 shades of a2 and then and
then maybe we go bishop c8 and we start
uh trading it away i feel like white
probably needs to play 94 or bishop
before start trying to trade
away the pieces that might challenge our
knight on e6 because if once again we
our entire game plan here is
ensuring the united states exactly
which is why bishop c8 is such a big
threat here and which is why you need to
be doing something about it something
like knight e4 94 or bishop before
because 94 yeah bishop 96 yeah yeah i've
got i've got uh
both knight takes f6 check on tennessee
and knight d6 ideas h6 may be a bit slow
and even b rugby rupert has actually
been played i was going to say even that
is not for us but rook b8 has been
played h6 definitely isn't
a strict requirement right but g5 annoys
me i don't particularly like the idea of
allowing g4 g5 so g5 and then 95.95
another game that had our attention very
much so on the break was the game
between
shaq and uh
ian and i left it to realm of 28. we
thought that this whole concept of shaq
rook d3 most especially was really
walking into an uppercut if you will
to quote mike tyson
uh rook takes c3 but uh somewhat
surprisingly because he also has plenty
of time jan missed a bit of a short
tactic here which is something he
generally is incredibly incredibly
strong at uh including quincy two here
was much stronger than taking on a five
straight away because
you felt this would have been winning
actually peter well 100 told us it would
have been close to winning which is why
i'm so confident in this assessment okay
because
we get to cheat a little bit by asking
by asking our friends
to inform us but
i think in general the idea of uh
putting one more heavy piece on on an
open file before taking on f5 just
strengthens the attack so much
uh and now you go to the x5 let's say
after queen c6
and what uh shaq replied uh in the game
uh which bishop takes a five in the game
was replied to by taking on the five
twice as we will see now is completely
impossible here just as the astra showed
because just gives mate on the back rank
exactly and in the game yeah all of
these captures have already happened and
here i think the point is you can play
roxy one check
and it still looks frightening though
doesn't it it is but you get counter
play against the white king after roxy
one check because you there's no easy
square to choose from if you play king
h2 here i have queen d6
potentially right and with defending
against queen
though
yeah queen b2 rook c5 and just go roxy 5
back it's not just rook c5 i mean the
fact that this continues is kind of
crazy but you can go
rook c5 for example h4 just to at some
point
create h3 for the king i think you want
h3 for the king because the king going
to g1 will always be met by
something to d1 when repeating moves
and
this
is surprisingly still holding
for you don't take on it like everything
loses
except i think it was h6
or maybe it was rook b5 immediately i'm
trying to remember black also needs to
unpin themselves so i guess h6 king h7
is quite logical here just to give
yourself a square because the knight on
e5 needs to be unpinned
um yeah this is a very like knight f6
check looks winning here but somehow
maybe maybe king h7 is a mistake
it definitely is yeah i'm going to go
down the variations on my board please
so you can see them queen d6 queen b2
double attack here on the knight on the
rook there's no other defense but the
move rook c5 you remember that also have
to take control over this square on fade
as it's made
and h4 i thought was a really good idea
h6 king h3 loses
rook v5 is the only move okay
okay queen a1 keeps the pin right and
now you play h6
don't ask too many questions
king h3 i thought why is this not
winning queen f1 is coming and i'm going
to made you right and the reason you
play rook b5 force queen a1 first is
that you have this move queen c5 which
is kind of amazing now that h6 is here
queen takes queen takes rook fade does
not make it mate uh it also wasn't mid
because it was check so in this
particular position it doesn't work the
queen on c5 is targeting e3
and that annoys
the king on h3 and it just
barely
holds i don't know how i don't know why
but the engine says yeah
i'm fine here i'm i'm okay i'm chilling
i'm terrified for in fact exactly i'm
just terrified this looks totally lost
to me and how he decided to go into this
variation
i have no idea and this is and this is
actually an improvement compared to
queen youtube which is kind
uh i guess the reason young went for
this instead of kundito because i'm
pretty sure he did not miss the idea of
quincy though i think you definitely can
see he's also looks crushing yeah i
think it's probably because he thinks
he's just completely winning here and he
felt you know why why look for more when
this is just winning right
but yeah this would have been a much
stronger move than bishop f5 and even
while these two extremely interesting
games are being contested there's a
third as well and as we were coming on
show i heard
lanier
better
yeah he's still he's still doing
completely fine but it's become a
complete mess and
let's catch up with where we left it we
left it just after the move bishop jesus
we had seen queen g2 and
knight e7 okay we we always knew that
the d5 pawn peter was the sensitive one
but 97 also protects the b5 pawn
allowing us to play five and before kind
of unmolested by uh not having even to
worry about knight takes b5 followed by
cleveland
uh knight c2 uh queen b7 g5 and here
after takes takes the engines at least
at the kind of a slightly shallow depth
preferred knight h7 to knight d7
uh
and somehow felt that this was more
precise
maybe just keeping white honest yeah and
actually completely ignoring like e3 e4
is playable here but the engine just
says i will play b5 before
and i will continue you know furthering
my own play on the queen side and your
play in the center is kind of empty 97
is also very a very human movement and
alireza continues playing in a very
direct fashion just goes king of two
before rook h1 pretty much saying yeah i
understand my coincidence is going to go
to rook h3 destroyed but yeah
creating a legends gun on on on the h
file okay h3o gh1 queen h2 and give mate
on the aha square exactly a plan that is
uh you know somewhat somewhat simplistic
but if it you know if it comes off it
ends the game well except for one small
problem by the time you've invested a
lot of time and energy in playing the
moves rook h3 rook h1 queen h2 king g8
and knight g8 just might sidestep the
whole shebang possibly i mean in the
meantime i've got to face some music
over on the queen side i don't know if
that includes c3
moves like c3 and b4 takes a3 one thing
that is going for him here is that the
center now is reasonably stable so let's
say if you play c3 bcba in particular ba
okay perhaps it's possible for white to
you know make a bit of a 180 here go
rook a1 and say right you know if i
actually get to pick up the pawn on a3
what's my problem i can no longer you
know i can switch to you know being a
pawn up in in some kind of a middle game
i definitely need to prep that whole uh
queen side break however it is i'm going
to prep it
uh in the meanwhile
what do you think about the king on h2
peter just
king on f2 pardon me uh it feels like
it
should be vulnerable but i just don't
know
it's unclear how yeah you can play
knight five and uh quote-unquote put
pile-up pressure on the e3 pawn but it's
protected enough i can go rook h3 and
continue
continue along with your business yeah i
don't see what that changes it's a very
beautiful square for the night but i
don't see what it does necessarily
because it's difficult to like in the
time you will actually attack the e3
pawn properly white will have all three
pieces on the h file and at that point
it might become slightly irrelevant
right right that i won a pawn on e3 and
got mated on
uh a double edged uh super sharp
position i mean he has a ton of time by
his standards by the way this is move 27
he has almost half an hour left
near yeah exactly
showing us that the the the body the
body double is
the body double is very very convincing
impressive so three exciting games uh
alejandra jump right in how do you like
them
uh i like this one in particular because
it's this one that you're looking at
between aliereza and lanier because it's
so unbalanced and even the engines are
thinking that so many different plants
are possible in this position a lot of
them look very scary for example going
back on a favor the night you're always
worried you're just gonna get mated
right and in some ways the engine wants
to bait you
into putting everything on the h file
and then going f6 and saying i'm okay
humans don't really think like that
humans don't really bait your opponent
to tripling on the h file and barely
animating you and surviving with the
skin of your teeth but saying hey your
rooks are now on the h file you're
very very discoordinated fascinating
position here the engine's top move is
knight f8 wow i'm sure a lot of things
can be considered roku6 is actually very
interesting as well
in many positions f6 rook takes f6 might
be an idea okay so i start to warm up to
the ideas behind k6 it's also not clear
what i'm doing in the status you guys
mentioned c3 really doesn't work uh we
do have to move knight f5 on the board
which was was something that we
considered in you guys were looking at
the move rook h3 right
i think rook h3 is cool this is an
interesting move that being said what is
one disadvantage of the move rook h3
this plants on the queen side no longer
as strong you put your rook on h3 maybe
it's time to do something like this and
b takes a3 the engine doesn't like but
it does like the move b3 b2 remind white
that there is a strong pawn on the b
file and if you throw all of your heavy
pieces on the this side of the board
well who's going to catch that guy right
so a little bit of counter pressure here
engines thinking that you have full
compensation for the pawn hard to play
the move knight f5 is technically not
the best move according to the engine
because of the move queen h3 and queen
h7 and knight g3 but it's also not such
an easy decision for someone to make why
because the queen on h7 it gives a check
but what's then what it's kind of
stranded on that square it's far away
from the rest of the pieces so queen h3
is the top engine move and it says
now i don't think this is going to
happen let's try to understand why after
knight f3 queen h3 you can't just play
for example let's put the mover okay
very very good very good we're looking
and the problem is this check
here and because this knight is on f5
yes and no one's defending it you get
this trick
aha takes queen takes f5 is just lost
things start collapsing and things start
collapsing yeah this knife's coming to
f4 this knight is taking on g7 and
hitting the knight with queen eight
eight queens
played by the way sorry queen h3 on the
board that guy's pretty good yeah yeah
yeah he's 2800. he's pretty good at
chess he
spotted an opportunity there of queen 87
and knight f5 it's a little hidden it's
very hidden it's very it's a it's a gem
and if he spots a linear might be in
trouble because you don't play knight f5
with the idea of playing knight e7 in
the next move right exactly exactly and
there's no good way to defend this
knight on f5 it looks pretty it's very
pretty very pretty knight on f5 but it's
actually the tactical target it's so
difficult to re realize that queen h3
amazing move by eli reza right
for seeing queen h7 and knight h5 lanier
needs to understand that he is very
close to being in trouble
why wouldn't
knight f8 just defending
the h7 square now be uh
it's the same trick
anyway
oh you don't even have to land on h7 ah
knight f5 anyway ooh that's actually
very painful peter yeah um
actually playing neither 5v7 here is a
feat of superhuman strength because to
take your movement yeah you're the most
difficult
yeah you seem like you give up two tempe
you've allowed queen h7 check the queen
was on g2 a moment ago and now it's
suddenly in your camp yeah
i i don't know how how you how
it's definitely not easy how possible
even it is to play knight to five seven
it just might be
because you calculate a couple of moves
and you realize that
and i'm dead exactly
your process of elimination forces you
to make a move that you don't want yeah
second best apparently once again the
gift of eyesight is very important king
of faith knight h5 kg7 is the second
line of the machine here yeah king f and
the machines are welcome night h5 thank
you
will not happen uh nicely defending the
by the way notice that the bishop on d2
does attack the pawn on b4 so your
knight needed protection you know this
old uh
what do they call it uh deflecting the
defender
type of business very exciting uh
tactics yeah
oh my i think this will definitely not
happen for 500. well again this game uh
very very sharp what has happened in the
shackriyar game it looks like they've
gone down chose yanchow's king f2
instead of king h2 which i think is
maybe slightly less troubling for black
because it's harder to hide this king
now from checks
it's it will be harder for for young to
create significant threats because uh
one of two it is just so susceptible to
all kinds of counterplay meaning that
white can't really let's say leave the
the the second round yeah the queen
can't really join the attack that easily
because rook b5 is but it's
understandable because in order to play
king h2 you needed to specifically see
that h3h4 is strong creating that square
on h3 for the king
and let me make sure that we're up we
are up to date with the players by the
way uh i wanted to ask the
well i actually wanted to ask that
question when my king was on h2 uh
could couldn't they have just taken that
you can but at the very least i can go
i think h6 king h7 maybe th
this was the point when my king was
somewhere yeah and also here i think
guru e5 i don't know why you're playing
q a one here because yeah it will take
c3 is a bit of a problem exactly i think
i have to play queen c3 but then i can
probably repeat
exactly like that would be at least an
immediate way for black to secure that
that were not worse i'm wondering if i
can maybe even kind of stick my neck out
now out a little bit and play instead of
all that clay h6 king h7 and pin the
knight on e5 and that might be ask if uh
if we're sure that the king of f2 is
safer than king on h7 but the fact that
the immediate draw seems to exist with
rugby firefox e5 is very relevant of
course
one of the most
more unusual positions i must say that
i've ever seen
uh this one let me just once again put
this on everything's been down yeah
it makes such a strange visual that
that this absolute pin that that is
absolutely crucial
uh and this you know your your kings in
this
crushing double check
uh killer uh
uh discovery and yet it's moves like h4
and h6 that are going to decide the
outcome of the game this is rather an
extraordinary position to me what's
exciting is that yeah you guys took on
g5
you guys are such punk drivers that's
amazing no i i was trying to refute that
i actually couldn't rook g5 was a draw
but it's a crazy draw because rook takes
g5 i thought why don't we just go h6 and
queen d1 and actually try to win
yeah
no but
with the king on f2
i i was wondering with the king on h oh
and h i see i see then then it's more
sane yes thank you yeah no not not with
the gang but downton did not get played
because as you point out the king
actually came to f two in the game kf2
queen d6 and oops excuse me we are up to
date with the players not rook takes g5
um
so what are you supposed to play here
with white
every move is zero zero
i mean it includes king g2 it includes
g5 a bunch of queen moves wow
king g3 is a draw
king g3
my goodness just
walking to yeah that's insane i mean
just a threesome a4 is a draw
everything's a draw every move pretty
much every move in this position
you're under a material yeah it's it's
pretty much zero i could imagine
that rook b5 you might find bothersome
and therefore you do play a move like a4
he's played king jutsu
king g2 with threats i think maybe now
you probably have created some threats
yeah queen of two queen of two at the
very least looks uh looks a bit
threatening
although i do have knight g6
well let's see what oh
my
what oh dear
no no no i think he wanted to go rook d1
takes e5 there in the end
right
i think he thought the rook on e5 is
protected by rook on d1 so he wanted to
go 97 rookie 7 rook takes e5 i think or
something i think he wanted to go check
yeah or possibly change they wanted to
go check and mate and realize wait a
second
richie
this is the second deal that richard has
blundered in the entire game i remember
against dioc this move 40 just it it was
lost it was an instant loss this is
night
seven he just resigned yeah well i mean
he is a full piece now well he went
knight d5
there goes the rook and that was it
yeah he was completely fine if you just
made some kind of a normal move there
rookie three rookie one yeah he wasn't
in any trouble
oh that's some kind of a weird you know
blind spot
this this clearly is not a reflection of
his understanding of chess or anything
it's just some kind of a glitch in uh in
the matrix there
wow
knight d5 what can we say this is
just huge horrifying blunder as his
intended
rook d a check king f7 rook f8 would be
brilliant
peter if it wasn't for the fact that the
rook is actually hanging pesky bishops
yeah exactly
oh my word oh
that that's pink that hurt that one is
rough and for mvl thank you very much
that's a gift well recently yeah
i mean after blundering horrif horribly
yesterday uh walking to mate
i mean i can't describe it
your suicide tendencies are high in this
event uh peter yeah there's been there's
been some
excellent excellent play and also some
howlers yes i mean you have to describe
it like this exactly it's it's a full
piece left left on the table
you know these are two move variations
you
you know you certainly don't expect them
to you don't miss a bullet yeah
so it's just it's just some kind of a
some kind of a malfunction and uh yeah
regrettable because richie
in every tournament he plays in he is
definitely one of the more entertaining
players to watch and exactly and he's
given us lots of excitement in this
tournament as well but also two of the
more
horrific blunders you are you're likely
to see this year this and also the one
the one against bogdan where
it cost him uh an immediate half a point
right after a very very well fought game
wow
yeah nothing else to say right uh open
and let's go to bucharest and a talk
with him as uh christian has him as a
guest
thank you uh yasser and we are first of
all welcome back to the studio
congratulations uh tell us a bit about
what happened uh
out of the blue just a complete accident
in the last move yeah it just feels good
of course to come back immediately after
my non-game yesterday
and here of course richard just simply
forgot that he never had d8 because the
bishop on i5 was covering
so you started off first of all let's
talk about the previous game between
youtube guys when he surprised you in
the groomfire and now you decided to
change the pace and play something
completely different how did you come to
that conclusion
no um of course like it's no secret that
i've
that i've played the queen's gambit
accepted already in the tournament so i
must have looked at it a little just a
little bit so
but richard managed to surprise me i
don't think he was taken aback at all by
uh by my choice and played this uh
interesting move order after which we
actually transposed to uh
to some semi-slav
and take us through the critical moment
in the opening when did you feel like he
surprised you
yeah like i want you after bishop b3 and
knight's history so
um
i mean i must have looked at it but you
know it's difficult to remember every
move order i mean this is a drawback of
playing something for
uh close to the first time that you know
i'm not aware of everything else so i
decided finally to
after deep thought in every of my move
to come back to this uh
um
you know
some islam
uh not take on d5 not accept the pawn
sacrifice yeah i assume did that feel a
bit too dangerous yeah i assumed you
want to knock
castle and then
i mean i assume i'm fine but you know
you have to know without my
uh because i think d4 if i uh or knight
d4 but
yeah so if i have to take on
only four
queen d8 knight g5 and
i mean uh i was not ready for like with
the pawn or even
yeah
it doesn't really it's not clear which
is best
you didn't want to see the same game yes
certainly not so i thought
i mean i have old memories of this
position but at least
they existed so this uh
but uh i must say that i probably
like i wasn't sure so here we came to
this position and i wasn't sure whether
knight d3 was a move or or whether it
was bishop e7 because
i know that here there are some moves
with g4
including g4 and
yeah you feel like uh you were trying
obviously to remember what the theory uh
said did you feel like he was still
within his theoretical knowledge he was
spending some time after all
yeah i think he mostly spent time
because
when i thought for so long he thought
maybe i don't remember well this uh
semi-slab lines which is true so he was
trying to figure out uh maybe if he had
a better option considering the
positions are very sharp
but
i have the intuition that this is what
he had prepared in case uh i went to
this so he was just trying to decide
which line to pursue yeah
i think so i'm not completely sure we i
mean we didn't talk much after the game
just to
you know he just told me that of course
he forgot the bishop on a5 but
yeah i mean understandably he didn't
want to talk much further that we're of
course talking about this final couple
of moves he started off with rook to e5
and you followed it up quite quickly
with knight to d7 of course and at this
point this move knight wha what were
your first emotions and thoughts when
you saw this move appear on the board
well i mean i just made sure that my
bishop on fire was controlling d8 and i
didn't take much time i must say to
to just take the work because anyway
but i thought that was already sort of
taking over because afterwards if you
want a knight f8 which
i think is kind of unpleasant and if he
goes hook he won back i think knight f8
anyway and these positions uh i thought
i mean i'm i'm definitely safe so
this was all i was asking for from
you know this adventures
an important victory uh for you how are
you going to uh approach now that you
have a much more positive mindset after
yesterday's loss in other last couple of
rounds you're playing deck tomorrow
yeah it's definitely investment
situations so of course uh i'm glad that
my mess up
of yesterday was corrected and you know
by uh luck of course but uh you know
blenders happen and
it always feels good to be on the
receiving end go get ready and we'll see
you tomorrow thank you very much
christian guys back to you thank you
christian thank you mvl i like it very
much much trust but verify that the
bishop controls the checkmating square
as
this victory
suddenly it's like hitting the
trampoline uh peter yeah and we are
going to have probably one more player
joining joining him on that trampoline
there because uh shakhtaryap just made
it with that horror yeah like i i saw
him play h7h6 there and i thought that
campbell like but what what is your
reply to queen f2 because it seems like
it's a bit strong
and i yeah and i asked the because i
couldn't really figure it out so i asked
the engine and the engine says plus plus
six and that was a good answer yeah yeah
fair enough going down today guys uh uh
what is going on
right dead loss
queen f2 is an absolute clinker yeah i
think what you mean
well what you mean what you missed is
that king jade i guess neither six czech
wins right and then the 94 yeah and then
i guess king 94 and i guess king g798
yeah king g798 is the nice i think i
think i think i know that one i think i
know what he pleases i think i can
explain it i think he missed 97 rook
takes c5 simply because
when your opponent is attacking you
don't like
the trading moves
don't feel to you like you're being
crushed right but then you realize
knight c5 queen b2 is made in three
which is also i think possible to miss
because it's a long movie like you're
you're calculating queen f7 but then you
probably have the perpetual between the
two kind of is a problem and we take c5
queen f7 you run out of checks kind of
straight away
yeah
queen six checking f2 i force you to
give a check from c2 i go to g3 there
are no more checks and the game is kind
of over ish done
because yeah you you lose everything
here g7 is a strong threat and check and
double check what no i don't know
something is really
gone there's something in the water
check the water check the playing hall
uh what is going on today guys blunders
galore that's all i can say uh blunder's
galore is he played rook f6 we are back
to we're back to this being equal-ish
what so you went from plus six to what
zero zero zero with in more than one way
apparently oh my word uh rook fc
wow i mean
you stop and you think he's gonna be 20
minutes
queen for five moves i mean that's one
of those moves that coordinates
everything you really understand what
you're doing you're going to go rook fa
check queen f5 check
and instead you play rook f6 because but
but i think
like from yon's side i i'm making
excuses here but you you don't expect in
this position your opponent to just
blunder from i think by this point jan
kind of realized he's not better
and before h6 happened i mean i think he
probably
once he plays king g2 here he realizes
there's all these shuffling maneuvers
black connections like rugby
rugby five frog d5 all of those moves
appear to be okay
and uh
he probably kind of made peace with the
idea that you know it looks pretty but
it doesn't actually win right and your
opponent makes a logical looking move
and you don't expect to suddenly be
winning
but i still don't really understand how
you don't calculate queen f2 for a bit
longer
he played rook f6 a bit too fast i think
well i i sit there and i i must say that
from my point of view the way i look at
chess i sit there and say you know what
are my threats what can i do uh
checkmate you know uh well and obviously
i want to play
rook to f8 so you you have these
fantasies that maybe you know for
example let me just play a5 fantasy
number one
oh rook f8
oh i know what all i really need to do
is get my rook to f8 and i can mate and
then you go okay well i do have a threat
in the position don't i i could play
queen f2 and look if hate me this is
very strange honestly so those thoughts
are
paramount in my mind there the the
forefront of what i would be trying to
do was white
and uh h7h6 i would would have thought
that's a perfect opportunity to do what
i want what's this queen f2 rook f8 i
get to play checkmate rook f6 now um
after the move rook f6 surprisingly
enough yeah you can play queen 21 you
can play queen d3 basically the polish
six is not nearly as important as
creating mating threats which are
winning and black now has
such significant mating threats yeah
queen i want we will return to this but
i want to i want to just once again
we've had two big blunders and in this
game we had like a blunder replied to
with a blunder right so i want to kind
of wash the taste a little bit away and
uh show you the other game
for a second and then i jump back to ali
yeah yeah
look at linear
this is actually one of the hardest
things in he's done it yeah he's played
this is legitimately one of the hardest
things in chess absolutely he took back
his previous move knight f5
97 f5 and now went knight f5 e7 that's
that's professionalism yeah doesn't make
knight five a good move but he realized
he's made a mistake and he spent two
thirds of his remaining time got to
grips with the idea that knight h5 is a
crushing threat
you know you swallow your pride you put
it back on a seven and you say yeah i
made a bit of a boo-boo here but yeah
but i it doesn't it doesn't mean i have
to you know commit commit to making
boo-boos for the rest of the game and
just design yeah like yeah
yeah my bad uh
i applaud the move very much knight f5
e7 but you were about to explain the
double blindness that we're experiencing
uh between these two extraordinary
tacticians i mean there is there is a
certain level of trust like when you
play somebody like shaq you don't expect
shock even if in i mean bad form and he
clearly is having a poor tournament but
still
he he spent some time and played h6
which you know send the evaluation from
zeros to six uh to six and a half but
you don't know that and uh you know
you've played him before you know he
generally doesn't blunder rooks in one
mode
so
no he does not but still
20 minutes for five moves
just just think for a bit he didn't he
didn't blitz out rook of six but he
didn't really uh you know sit down and
evaluate queen of two properly and for
amateurs in the audience uh
the those double blindness are
very common
more than world championships i remember
very vividly uh a magnus carlson vicious
yeah uh it was like
the two trusting yeah opponents we were
doing that game live i was i was
commenting and commenting for the
official stream and we went on break
as
magnus uh
played king g2
and uh
in i one of us needed to basically run
to the producers because we didn't we
didn't have an earpiece we were kind of
communicating by by gestures right so i
started kind of waving and uh and and
not shouting because i wasn't sure we're
not being uh you know like live mics
but my waving didn't really register so
we were actually the only stream which
did not show the one minute of magnus
blind was sitting there at the board
like because he was clearly afraid to
move he realized the moment as usual the
moment you release the piece onto the
awareness you press the clock and you
freeze in horror as you realize what
you've just done and the game is kind of
gone and he's just sitting there afraid
to breathe exactly and we're showing
some commercials
and
vicious goes a5 a4 on the queen side
rather quickly and magnus just kind of
immediately drags the king back back
from from d2 so that the tactic no
longer exists and somewhere at that
point we come back on there when
everything is gone like and we have to
describe it in wars instead of showing
you pictures i think it was the only
stream which which did that i was nice
yeah it was a kind of a remarkable piece
of better you just really captured the
moment
well done well done me and soppiko we
were not very happy about that yeah but
okay so we we definitely had a case of
double blindness right here and you're
you're advocating for the move queen d1
creating these uh
check
well dastardly uh threats
now why doesn't queen d1 they turn the
tables even more
and shockingly you might have to play
rook f2 here because i mean allowing
roxy to check it's not great
rook f6 is just empty this is another
point why why you why do you play rook
f6 you you in many in many cases you
will not even be taking on h6 it's a
very seriously very very empty gesture
right it's just mystified and three
minutes for shock who are these players
right and queen d1 isn't the only move
but he also works with somewhere let's
see where it goes just don't put it on
d5 queen d1 works very nice let go let
go shot come on let go it's good all
right it's good you survived the worst
let go i mean it's gonna be okay
he doesn't i must i must say that that
reminds me of a number of scholastics
where but they hold their finger their
kind of finger on top just to
look around and okay i didn't blunder
anything you let go yeah how much time
yes three minutes and 30 seconds shaka
is for 11. it doesn't move 36 though
it's not sorry sorry
okay uh but yeah well kind of a
remarkable sequence considering yeah
rook f6 attacks the queen queen d1
forces rook after i mean i'm not sure
about forces but yeah you you provokes
you're not really taking on
we're not really taking on h6 yeah well
especially in view of this massive
threat rooksy two to your own king your
king and uh and
this would just be uh it just goes work
of two very calmly
very calm
everything within plants yeah
everything is under control yeah i in
the meantime i feel rather tasered by
this rook f6 rook f2
wow i can't even it's one of those i
can't even moments uh look moments again
for those of you who might be joining us
late this was really a shocking moment
right here at case of double blindness
uh just about everything is even uh but
most especially i think
and i think we need to point out why
rook b5 let's say doesn't lose to queen
f2 and h6 does if you play queen f2 here
we can play knight g6
and rook takes c5 doesn't knock the
queen away from the f6 square
exactly so rugby 5 85 you have no mate
queen b2 is made by queen e5 and queen
of six is just a trade of queens so
you're actually i think maybe even worse
in this special maybe queen f7 makes a
draw maybe it doesn't
uh but with the rook on c5 this would be
completely unplayable after h6 you can't
play knight g6 because rook takes c5
uh rook takes e5 and queen of six is
just made in three exactly uh
i was trying to figure out another thing
that i thought maybe explains the
blunder is maybe knight h4 check i
thought maybe he he thought knight h4
check here
sorry which moment peter after knight g6
knight g65 roxy five now the sword check
is a bit tricky actually because
uh
but king g one queen of five no it's not
it's not even really that tricky one
yeah yeah it's completely fine
yeah it's just inexplicable
why he thought it was fine and why uh
jan didn't check it for an additional 30
seconds because the calculations really
aren't that difficult after queen after
and by the way i'm just going to refresh
my board by the way queen d5 is
basically saying there's no reason why i
have to
make a repetition i don't have to play
queen d6 or something queen d5 checked
and i think he wants to lure the king to
a dark square and then go back to d6 i
think that's his plan and i think it's a
solid plan as well just like king h2
yeah put the king on a square where the
knight cannot be unpinned without grave
harm coming to wipe and put the queen
back on the six alejandro as a chess
coach you've seen everything you've seen
blunders galore double blindness uh
your explanation for what we've just
seen because it's so rare at this
exalted level i want to say that uh you
just see these uh guys
chess is hard chess is hard i mean look
at these guys right they're the best of
the best they're top of the line right
and even they miss
relatively simple things right i think
that a lot of our viewers in their
classical games would be like yeah i can
find that i can find all of that i would
see it if i had such an opportunity
yeah so it does happen it happens at the
highest levels it happens to every grand
master
it's uncommon
it's very uncommon to see this kind of
double blunders especially in a round
where richard report also blundered
a rook a rook
so it's been a strange day
we had two very solid games we have a
fascinating struggle alareza dominguez
and two very
very strange games i mean it's not just
this double blunder that i have not been
able to understand of this position
rook d3 rook takes you three left such a
mystifying taste in my mouth yeah that
he survived afterwards because the
computer says he survived great but that
you even got to this position remarkable
yeah
young
if
as we assume this is now holdable for
black and maybe not even that difficult
to to hold
and
i don't know who they invite to i mean
there will be a press conference
or an interview with with christian and
i wonder who who they asked to talk to
them and like what that conversation
will look like right
and uh yeah i remember the absolutely
remarkable game between uh shaq and
richie
and
if there was ever a time to interview
both players that was the game uh that
would be it and maybe this is a game
where
both players or explain themselves or
alternatively just give them a pass
honestly right like just go away this is
not going to be i mean it's not going to
be fun for them explaining why why you
know this never had yeah
so
yeah as somebody who you know in a
previous life
wasn't was in that chair yeah i mean i
understand it's like i'm not really
advocating for it it's uh you know these
are the human interest stories we we get
you know when something out of the out
of the ordinary happens in the game but
as a player you don't really enjoy
having to explain why why you had such a
horrible horrible moment of
yeah
of blindness yeah it's just tough it's
just tough uh let's switch games for a
moment as we go back uh to
the game of alireza for a moment because
the shovels are kind of blowing up over
here too
we left it basically after this move
knight e7 take i can take my move back
yeah knight g3 potentially knight g3
creates a threat of queen h7 followed by
knight h5 g8 knight takes h5 i think it
looks very strong
so let me just put
and you were about to land
me a vicious tactic
yeah gh knight h5 and it looks like
we're breaking through here because the
bishop is hanging and this is why
lanier's move was
required if the rook were here yeah i'd
have the defense yeah we got you six
here which explains why he played rook
a6 and he played a6 and elireza picked
up this pawn on before using the
overloading of the queen on b7 to
do this i think black is probably still
okay yeah i would play rook a8 here and
ask not not i mean yasser took that pawn
in his mind before yeah
i
because we still need to spend a tempo
on protecting the rook on e8 and giving
white additional 10 people rugby one i
kinda hate personally i think it's maybe
playable but i would i would start by
playing rk8 and if you take on d5
which is pos i think it's playable but
now we take on d5 first
two force knight e2 okay
and then we play something like there's
a number of moves here which interest me
queen b3 looks interesting uh rook a2
followed by something c3 might even the
simple c3 might be very playable
iii is playing yeah rookie iii is not
i'm not happy yeah this is right here no
no it's very white this is because i
think knight takes d5 is just never
going to get played i think after after
okay you make some kind of a
consolidating move i don't know exactly
and and
and the truth is this night on e7 is
actually a very defensive night i'm very
happy to allow that knight to just kind
of live on its uh own it's not
bothering anybody is is there anything
to be said for like uh
the h line i mean
there are no threats i mean i think the
position is way too open for white to go
back to trying to give me well
let me be persistent at least
but
as i try to be persistent or stubborn as
the case may be let's jump to bucharest
and anastasia and christian
i have to say guys everybody here is in
complete shock because something is in
the water today here in bucharest but
also in a previous game specifically for
richie rapport and i have to say richie
is
well he's generally self-critical so i
think he lost a lot of confidence when
he lost in one move against both on
daniel deck and right now he's a
completely different player than what we
are used to seeing from him and this
game yes as you guys were mentioning it
was just mutual blindness i don't think
any of the players saw that because i
went to the playing hall and uh nepal
was quite relaxed he was just like
walking around uh just like mamadiarov
he didn't feel like he escaped any sort
of dangerous moment i think it was just
a mutual of blindness in that game how
about yourself anastasia what do you
think happened there yeah it seems like
we went on two different plane holes i
felt completely different i felt so much
pressure in the air actually um last for
the last few moves
and
actually for me both of them they look
so concentrated now and focused on the
game they feel maybe that something is
happening but they didn't but i felt
maybe that nepal really doesn't like his
position that much anymore this is this
was my thoughts what i also noticed that
actually all the games in the center of
the whole are finished so we have two
games
in different angles and those spectators
move to either to the right or to the
left you know it looks a little bit
funny in the playing hall at the moment
so i don't know maybe
all players are tired maybe it's
something about their what you said
christian but something is happening
right now yes and nobody understands
what will be the outcome of this game uh
literally it's very interesting that you
mentioned tension because also at the
seconds uh as well the assistant i would
say of uh dominguez and fioruja if you
were just that as well as dominguez is
second they were both at the same time
in the playing hall watching intently
the game so there's definitely some
pressure nevertheless as you were
mentioning you thought nepo and
mamedyarov were very tense i thought
they were quite relaxed let's see how
this game plays out guys back to you
thank you for the
on the site if you will nothing like
being there in person to witness the
tension and i remember this was the
topolof game uh from vikanze there where
he's uh where gary kasparov you know
sacrifices the two rooks
and he just had
the these photos of the spectators
it's just like it's so classic it's so
good uh very very exciting duels uh
going on there um did you come to some
conclusion about
i ali raza's position i started by
feeling that i will be able to refute
your rook h4 reasonably comfortably but
no i think it's a very playable idea and
uh
yeah i
i still feel like black should be fine
but it's it's not easy to react to at
all you're you're sort of a very cave
mini idea of luke h4 dh1 queen h38 mate
because i say that it seems like black
made so
so significant advice as you know
especially
right but knight fe 2 just covers kind
of everything once you they can be two i
play not fb2 that's a good protection
yeah keeping the other one to to control
the f5 square very importantly you can't
really allow knight to five here and
then you just want to double and then
and then treble treble on the h file and
then you
crash through
hopefully you've made yeah right that's
the intent
yeah
and like you say uh caveman but uh it
does land with uh some effectiveness now
on the other hand um
we're upon up but i i see no reason to
to play uh yeah
no that's egregious
yeah egregious now you had also
mentioned knight f2 i would consider
that yeah that
you would welcome
the move queen takes b2 because you
would think that maybe it will be one is
something yeah just kind of uh opening
up additional additional
a move that uh warms your heart i was
actually
advocating for knight g2 which the the
engines don't like at all but i see
knight f82 is a well knight ge to ah
the other one controls the g5 square so
i thought i still don't have to worry
about knight five all that much and i i
wanted to keep the more active knight on
the floor but yeah the i think the
engines are not not a fan and knight fp2
is a
decent one i must say i always like
dominating my opponents
active pieces so keeping the knight on
g3 just to keep this knight on e7 honest
and saying you know like you're not i am
never
going to allow you to play the move
knight f5 uh i like that and the 92 and
the times peter of the players two
against three in a very very sharp
position and who's got the two who's got
the three yeah
226 and dominguez 305 encounters i still
say that's an imposter
linear i made the body devil
looks remarkable but uh
he
oh my god
and we we should be paying uh paying
more attention i think to this board
because on the other
all kinds of repetitions are now very
much in the air
the queen and bitsu can be chased and uh
i mean
not only that but they're going to reach
mu 40 pretty quickly
these guys well not quite there yet yeah
by bilinear standards this is not a very
you know horrible time trouble he's got
like two to two and a half minutes for
uh what is now uh seven moves to make uh
once he's gone through kg8 kt8 is like
moving the rook away from an open so
open file is maybe not very uh uh
intuitive but i think he just wants to
pick up on i think
and uh play on because he's not really
getting mated on the edge file very much
with the current uh configuration of the
white pieces queen g4 or queen h3 is all
logical but i think we can reasonably
safely take on bitsu and proceed from
there
are you so sure though because that i
mean i kind of want
to agree that yeah but each file
honestly
you were making a very salient point on
this topic earlier yeah
i can eventually once you create your
your election gun on the h1 i can't
break king of fade and say
a walk away go on yeah and after yeah
after rook b1 uh
queen a3 let me drop in and say kind of
hinting that the the pawn on e3 is not
as safe as uh you know as all that i
mean i i don't have a comfortable way of
attacking it but i mean knight g6 we
were queen of four rookie seven or
something you know knight f6 queen
eve queen of four rookie seven
blocking my rock hb1 i mean i understand
why i mean game is still very you know
very very much ongoing here i don't know
who i like better but that is a
protected pass pawn on c3 yeah there
will be one rook d8 maybe and i mean
it's kind of a very strange sharp
position where yes we have a protected
passer but it will get controlled by the
knight on c3 at some point
and def i mean d5 is in these structures
is quite weak like if we take one e7
here and in particular if you play queen
takes e7 and white goes knight c3 9g too
uh he's gonna win a four straight away
without even including would be one
exactly it's a good square i mean you
were also aiming for it immediately i
did yes i did so and they're obviously
like this is not going to happen but
there is a very cute construction like
if you if you if you can give by three
tempe here somehow let's go c3 yes rook
h3
okay queen f6 yeah this is the this is
the one you know this is the one i
wanted to show uh i remember it was a it
was a magnus carlsen's what made it
[Laughter]
nobody sends him christmas cards they
forget his birthday
night but maybe
maybe maybe we we we did it
this might be uh
this might be mean
yeah okay couldn't f4 does sort of
invite queen b8 though
like a queen f4 is uh excuse me i'm
going to have to refresh sorry uh queen
f4 sorry
it's sort of in white screen v8 it's
kind of a bailout that uh
yeah and you're not interested goes
knight c6
if blake gets like before 93 here blek
is in command i think you go rp1 now and
we might actually get a transposition to
the position
oh there's a move here rook h7 now okay
h7 h7 now yeah
oh rook h sounds a huge move in this
position ooh these are and by the way if
it was a puzzle if it's a puzzle rush
you play rook h7 immediately yeah
because you know it exists but if you
don't know anything you might not think
about it but
another blind spot here
rook h7 on the board alireza doesn't
miss these tactics it's not dead lost
shockingly you can play with rookies
on to the f6 square yeah you need to
sell the thread of course is rook g7
yeah once you get over the shock factor
of rook h7 which by the way could really
freeze you freeze you yeah
then you realize you have to defend f6
because rook takes g7 queen f6 or kh1
will just be made right you have to
defend the only way to defend it is
rookie sex is the only move in the
position
but yeah the entire sequence is very
difficult to play because after queen h4
or i mean rook gh1 is also strong each
one maybe like takes d4 now creates
enough count to play though why happily
happily for black
rock ge8 wait wait wait wait wait i just
i mean rook g7 is much better for white
here right yeah if all else fails we can
go to g7
it's yeah it's kind of winning kind of
running
can i start with rook g8
okay so so rook h7 is on the board we're
expecting rook e6 well hoping because i
think everything else can allow us mates
everything else is made yeah yeah and
sorry dude besides the move rook h1
could i play queen yeah this is what i'm
sure yeah this is what i think i saw on
alejandro's screen because knight takes
d4 is once again i think the suggested
move in this position oh really
oh because it controls h8 i was
wondering why can't you go 94 rook she's
having queen h6 through h1 yeah yeah but
the point is this end game i think is
lost like if no you're controlling h8 no
but you don't go into the end game
sorry you don't go for mate oh this is
awesome yeah this is also pretty good
it's also pretty good yeah
but i mean just queen takes d4 here i
don't think you hold this end game i
think the same game is bad it's pretty
decent 24. yeah take a look at the room
has to get to rookie six though
and he has 23
exactly ah that's the linear we know now
now we recognize him like he'll find
rookie six
yes out of necessity on three seconds it
will get played yeah
and he still has four moves to time
control four tough moves to time control
but rook h7 is a great spot oh what a
miss by linear four three
two
one uh one second
one yeah on one second oh
why but this looks pretty busted yeah
yeah oh with 30 months having to play
knight takes d4 is just such a such a
dispiriting dispiriting idea you know
especially when you just played knight
c6 e7 probably yeah
yeah very clean and you have to take on
d4 you resign
yeah
rook
takes between h6 and rook h1 as well as
rook h1
immediately provokes
probably the only move in the position
yeah but then you have a choice right
yeah even i mean the end game is lost
and you can also not play the ending
like you can go rook to hd4 here
and black goes rook g8 and uh yeah i
mean this is yeah i mean two seconds on
two seconds yeah this guy and i wonder
if i reza will continue looking for made
because i'm pretty sure he understands
the end game is borderline winning but
no i mean playing for nate with rook
takes d4 has got my uh yeah my vote but
after d8 now that the rook cannot reach
the h file yeah you take we take but
it's you don't you don't create amazing
i can go with take c3 there right
because i control h8 exactly that's the
whole trick
this is this is why we have to take on
d4 because yeah
okay
they're looking for his first victory
in the event and uh knight takes d4 so
after oop excuse me i'm going to do
something i
i have to do sometimes i have to go back
and forth knight takes d4 what's the
cleanest
guys
we always look for the
easiest
win if there is such a thing
i'm not i still feel like the sun game
is completely winning i i can see rook
takes and queen takes deep i can see
that i i think the engine disagrees i
think the engine now they're about the
same okay
i just i just don't see how this ever
holds i take with the rook i play knight
c3 knight g2
i mean this center never holds they just
get picked off one by one the the the
knights working in conjunction
they just exert so much pressure against
the center that like it just i i can't
imagine this called even being difficult
i mean right not not just
the overall result but also like i just
i just don't see how this is difficult
for what
but yeah rook takes d4 like if you want
to continue playing against somebody who
made his last two moves on two seconds
and one second of course he can play
rook takes d4 and
you know continue asking questions but
it's a mystery against somebody like
linear it's a mistake to assume he will
make make many more inaccuracies he
didn't he did miss rook h7 already and
he is playing on increment but the yeah
he has made two only moves in a row so
far that is
kind of yeah yeah yeah you just go for
this yeah
it's the right way it's the right way
you're kind of sad you will have to play
up past the time control you'll have
kind of a dry technical task instead of
gloriously giving mate somewhere exactly
but
a win is a whip yeah i i think you're
pretty confident here with white that
the end game is
close to close to winning or just
winning it just go queen takes d4
very nicely done and the players will
make time control yeah let's move 39
alireza with uh any capture on you i
assume
takes d4
by far blocking uh
blockading and setting up for knight c3
and uh
clipping the pawn on d5
yeah
whoa
um
jesus my goodness what a round guys
uh rook h7 uh
lanier overestimating his position
missing his beautiful tactic yeah he's
going to find himself in a losing ending
by the time time control has been
reached and i think ali
uh he's uh just got up because that's
moved 40 feet let's move forward yeah
he doesn't need 30 years
suffer they're choosing between bonus
all kinds of very very similar moves
yeah just collapses right yeah the the
way to try to fight for black would be
like if black could somehow get a pair
of rooks off the board
black chances would improve very very
significantly but i don't see how you
actually trade anything before you've
lost your entire strength how can you
trade that beautiful work on d4 i mean
just don't yeah it's so i mean you will
maybe once the d5 pawn falls maybe then
some files will get open that will allow
you to trade the rope but by that point
it probably will be too late not g3 yeah
exactly this is knight c3 knight g two
knight of four
the sixth issue we could already play
three four in the previous move up by
the way yeah we have more pieces than
our opponent yeah e3 four just pick up
on d5 put the other one on d1 on e4
yeah
it's actually very easy
yes it is not difficult yeah not
difficult wow so perhaps time to revisit
our uh
mutual blindness our other game yeah in
which black is seemingly not completely
fine and also rich move forward so
jan is now
when we left the queen d1 rook f2 queen
d5
king h2 yeah and jan chose clearly i
think if he goes king ji2 here shaq just
very happily gives a check from d5
so ian says uh let's play goes knight g3
uh avoiding the
the repetition black does rugby five yan
relinquishes the being on the long
diagonal and now shark played drug d5
and the current threat is rugged
using the fact that there will be knight
of three check there in the end
uh swapping everything off and black is
currently upon up so
i assume white still has enough
compensation for the pawn but yeah this
is like night and day
uh to i mean
not even counting the blunder
black clearly has has improved h7h6 is
now on the board giving squares for the
black key
precisely yeah the pin the pin is gone
there's actual counter threads white
needs to uh pay attention to and uh
progress not at all there are some pawns
on the queen side that might have a say
give black a few moves c5 b5 c4 and uh
clearly an unbelievable amount of
progress has been made by my shock here
towards towards equality at least wow
wow just wow peter
yeah it's been a it's been a wow kind of
round
and not in
necessarily in the greatest possible way
no i mean some games still are
very very interesting very very nicely
played apart from this one mistake by
the year which probably ends up deciding
the game that game was very well played
yeah yeah that game featured a lot of
very difficult decisions it was very
well fought and you get that and type
pressure you blunder a move that you
didn't think about because h7 is covered
your mind just for one second didn't
realize that at this precise moment of
h7 is playable
very understandable blunder bilin yeah
the other blunders
yeah the the the other stuff is is much
much harder to explain
um yeah i mean sometimes it just feels
like chess can be so it's such a cruel
game uh you could defend so incredibly
well as lanier did
one just yeah you know brief hiccup rook
h7 and then it's all gone and yeah he he
made the sequence of only moves to get
here and here is not very inviting
it's not a very good position so it's a
kind of a rare-ish case of
one mistake sort of deciding the game
you you you make a mistake large enough
you just don't let get you you the game
doesn't let you back in yeah
we are going to take a break everybody
as our panel recharges and
digests what just took place in this
very eventful of round seven we'll see
on the other side of the brink see you
then
[Music]
if you have kids you already know st
louis has a ton of fun stuff for
families to do like the magic house or
the science center and if you really
want to be a stellar parent come see all
the new stuff there is to discover at st
louis union station with a new mirror
maze light shows and the 20-story high
st louis wheel it's enough to make any
parent feel like a
star st lou is
always exploring
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
and active communities
it sounds like life
and it's what you hear
when you really listen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when you visit st louis you'll probably
want to watch the cardinals or the blues
what about after the game heading back
to the hotel would be a major error
instead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the blues
their name at the national blues museum
broadway oyster bar or even the
legendary blueberry him so whether you
love the cardinals the blues or the
blues come play with us
and you guys know i can't play this
right
st lou is always exploring
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the final segment of
today's uh coverage we are watching
round seven of the bucharest
granchester
chess classic and these are the current
standings with only two games still
running
wesley and the one are ahead mbl is now
in clear third and will most likely be
in clear third now that we know what the
other two positions are
and these are the
the two games still ongoing with yanipam
nishi on the white side against uh
shakhma mujarov and ali reza ferruga
much much better against linear probably
winning but there are still some
technical uh technical hurdles to be
overcome but the story of the last i
don't know 15 minutes 20 minutes i would
say i don't know exactly how long our
break was
is yanipanesh apparently is on a quest
to
lose lose a game which seemed unlosable
as recently as i don't know five moves
ago
successful yeah very very very
successful look at the position on the
board yes exactly i mean black's
position black's pieces are all
beautifully centralized the white rook
which was in total control of the f-file
for
as long as we can remember is now on e2
and doing absolutely nothing yeah
serving a defensive purpose in his
and he the the
vulnerable to a knight f4 check should
this knight on g3 ever leave the knight
had to go back from h5 to g3 black has
completely stabilized queen e6 rook d5
covers all the central squares and black
has a very healthy extra point which is
about to actually start
you know
heading towards yeah and suffocating at
the same time
this losing position that we're
observing on the board was just
a scared ten moves ago a plus six that
was for a brief moment because
until move 35
it honestly was a reasonably well played
game
you could say there were some
opportunities missed and uh yes sir sort
of scrolling past a couple of them there
yeah but
those were difficult calculations and
you could see how you make mistakes
there and somewhere around there yeah
there's this very curious position
around move 32 33 34 where there's
everything pinned but white can't really
make any progress yeah the queen don't
move
one big miss
one biggest and then we get to this
position where
white is upon down but black is
completely hamstrung by all the pins and
the back rank weaknesses and all that
but it's difficult to create a threat
and white generally can't really make
much progress and then shah after not
even that long of a
uh pause makes the move h7h6 which
loses to queen of two and
immediately i want to say this is not
even difficult calculations this is
something that young normally would
calculate
pretty much instantly and wouldn't it
wouldn't even trouble him all that much
you know the idea of bringing the
queen to the file and starting to give
checks
really isn't that difficult it's
basically what the entire play previous
to that point was aimed at and geared
towards exactly so
instead he missed that opportunity he
played rook f6 which actually this is
still this is still fine for white even
though forced rook
yeah i'm not sure why this is so
attractive but i i very much doubt in
particular i think move 39 was sort of
the the start of the downward spiral if
you if we go to move back to king h26
there
i'm pretty sure that after king h226 if
you actually play king judo here mm-hmm
move 39.
yeah i'm pretty sure shaq just goes 25
check i don't think black has any
particular winning chances in this
position because the knight on h5 is
very dangerous there's still plenty of
uh initiative on the king's side i don't
think black has much in a way of
progress to be made i mean
i'm not sure if you can play something
like b7 b5 but it doesn't look like it
gives black
uh you know much much of it again just
to compare the current position you have
an active rook you have an active queen
you have an active knight as we flash
forward to today's moment
yeah and
honestly the the next five moves or so i
i'm sort of kind of hoping jan doesn't
have to give an interview today because
he will be extremely extremely uh
unhappy with himself yes but
and
in general i don't really like the genre
very much but i want to say
knowing ghana a little bit i've been
i've been around him you know we've
we've worked together
i get the feeling
at some point and this is what i kind of
feared for him
i get the feeling he found queen of two
afterwards he saw it and hindsight
because i i think
this is this is what in particular for
somebody like jan who is you know
self-reflection and and
extreme levels of self-criticism are his
like this is where he thrives you know
it's right it's his spiritual home you
know i feel i very much recognize those
emotions
and it was crucial for his well-being in
this game that he doesn't realize queen
of two was winning
because he is one of those players who
would struggle actually to stop thinking
about it once he realizes just how big
of an opportunity was missed early in
the game exactly and the way he played
from
let's say move 13 on onwards like very
quickly
issuing all chances of repetitions just
continuing to play for a win in a
position which is becoming worse and
worse with every move yes it really does
feel like you know the play of a man who
at some point realized he was just
winning in one move and frustration and
does he can't shake off that extreme
frustration of you know a mistake of
this magnitude right i could be
completely wrong but
i think this is how this is how it
sounds yeah a lot of chess players do
suffer from this perfectionist
complex and they they expect that their
moves will always be if like you know
the highest quality and they really
become severe with themselves when they
live up to that
extraordinarily exalted uh
reflection that they have
of the of the people i know reasonably
well he is one of the harshest to
himself
uh and yeah
for him the the idea that he
could just win basically within the game
in one move and just absolutely waltz
bastard right would be very very
difficult to uh to ignore which is why i
always admired players
like by the way ben larson
who you know
forgot everything everything that's
history that's history you know this is
the moment oh no my god there's an
opportunity for me to win the game this
is great bang bang bang bang bang and uh
oh you mean i was lost earlier too bad
it's an it's an incredibly valuable
skill to have exactly
people struggle with it i personally
struggle with it for me it was always
very like
very harmful to to my continued play in
the game if i realized that i made a
very very big mistake earlier
and
shaking it off and
yeah treating it as you know something
perhaps
once the game is over it's
it's not impossible but on a bad day you
really struggle with it and i think this
is what we're watching but once again
obviously all of these types of
conversations are you know conjecture
but very very much conjecture i i think
it's a voice of experience speaking as
well by the way the position keeps in my
opinion slip slips sliding away
and aeons positions getting worse and
worse as b5 has just been played we're
about to see c4 cementing the knight on
d3 and shaq is taking over this game
has
has uh has uh farouza done the same
thing in his game uh alejandro well
after going into an end game two nights
against the rook the rooks also have an
extra pawn but the problem is look at
this beautiful pieces on the center
coordination e5 knight on d4 knight on
c3 it's hitting
all of it it's hitting all of the
structure that black has and at this
point you have choices the move that
alireza played rookie 5 looks okay he
could have been more direct there was
the knight c6 96 but also if we could go
back for a second there i was wondering
about something just one move one move
prior to the position the position yeah
like somewhere here yeah foreign g8 i
thought e3 4
it's so it's a movie you kind of hate to
make but i think if you take g4 you lose
the exchange
i thought it was a very clean solution
yeah e4 because g4 knight e4 yep g7 e6
e7 c6
those are the easy ones
uh and if you play king f7 here
yeah this is also an immediate fork if
you play king f7
i go knight g6
same idea for king yeah and then i got
95 check and it seemed to me like this
also sort of ends the game on the spot
because if you can't reply to e4 with d4
what are you doing yeah it's not
something that you want to do but you're
absolutely right it looks like you could
just cleanly win in exchange and if you
can play e4 and obviously if you get to
play knight t if you get to play 95 or
e5 check even like yeah the game seems
to be effectively over agreed not that
rookie five lets anything go i'm pretty
sure that basically it's almost the
problem putting here here is that even
if ali alireza keeps on missing quote
unquote forced wins like there's no
improvement here for black you just wait
until white finally finds a for you know
yeah because your position is you're not
moving any piece anymore yeah
rook d6 walks into what you've suggested
peter simply e4 and it's all over and if
you don't play rook d6
basically these rooks are
well tethered to the pawn on d5 and if
you start moving your king back at a
certain moment you know white's king
just kind of waltzes up the board and
soon
you're out of moves you don't want to
play king g7 and walk into a fork and
next is next up is king g5 um
i mean that's what the horse is dead
guys leave it alone yeah it's really bad
it's dead and also i
i've been uh
i've come back to
the uh sort of the crucial moment in the
new policy game if we go back to that
really
important turning point on move 36 i
think
where he didn't play quinn f2
i think
i've
i found maybe a chess explanation for
why uh for why uh what what happened did
happen after king h7
which is a move you do consider because
rook of fate was a major major threat
the the winning line here i don't know
if it's the only one but it might be
uh
actually no there is but the other the
other thing is also quite cute and not
easy to find
the simplest way to win here is
something i think it is possible to miss
or miscalculate the winning move here is
replay c5
25 we give a check from f7 and then we
just go knight f6
and
your first eye test there's this king on
g2 which is protected by nothing right
and black has checks
but as it turns out the black has like a
couple while giving away pieces yeah
like one and then you start giving away
material because the king on f3
cannot be checked by anything pretty
much without giving up like full rooks
uh
so
if you spend more than three seconds on
this position you will realize that
there is like you have to play ruka took
an h2 but you have no expectation of
this ever being a perpetual because the
king once again marches up the board to
e4 5v6 and white wins
uh
it's not a difficult like i think that
i'm struggling to explain this from a
purely chess point of view i think it's
just he did not assume his position
could suddenly become winning in one
go in one move yeah yeah
wow
and the other the the the cute one that
i mentioned is actually cute enough for
me to to make us show it on the board
after queen of two king h7
the second way of winning the opposition
queen f2 king f7 yeah king h7 we can
play knight of six check
and after king g6 which looks natural we
play rook takes g5 here
what what
baroque g5
[Music]
we win the king this is mate and
otherwise we win the queen on d6 like
king of 794 check
on it check here yeah and they said this
end game is very very straightforward
but five check is a cute little move you
also are very very allowed to
have to miss but still
it's findable and rookie five is also
findable all of these things are
are definitely the one thing that
doesn't win after king h7 is arguably
the most natural move in the position
which is seven check which after king g8
actually leads to a position that is
probably going to be defended
amazing yeah because i mean rook f7 yeah
that's the the eye candy you know like
you've got made in three years that's
the one you want to make with exactly
that's the one that actually throws the
win away i'm actually here
i'm i'm surprised that this is a not
winning as well like right i mean you're
gonna yeah you give me a check
i'm sorry and holds on grimly
the grim the grim
it's still very hard for me to believe
that this somehow isn't that clean i
mean
somehow
the machine just says this is not i
don't know right okay yeah yeah we don't
we don't doubt it but yeah queen f2 is
is a difficult move
not to play five rooks e6 is zero zero
zero
queen of five roxy
wow
and by the way uh and remarkably in this
tournament we have seen
lavonne
win two games with black pieces
and uh we just saw how many mbl today
getting a whole rook from
shaq uh daniel diock one with black
against richard that's right yeah
we're being told this is going to be the
fifth win what i was trying to count is
how many decisive games in general we
have had we've had one one
[Music]
three three
one two yes
and uh
and to today into the day
two
and maybe we get
i think i'm missing one round right no
three two we'll get three today sorry
i'm sorry
this would be eleven yeah that's that's
right yeah this would be 11 decisive
games yeah
should these two games be decisive which
these two games so that's actually six
five in white's favor because at one
point black was leading i believe but no
longer no longer the case i i think
there was definitely like
yeah
i'm pretty sure like after around three
maybe black was actually ahead
um
by the way i think the harvest is about
to take place in the farouzia game
as
white has just
laid the table very very nicely
for capturing the pawn on d5
last few sequence of moves we saw a
rookie five
lanier
backed up with his king and when rook h8
and knight f3
threatens
a double attack the pawn on d5 as well
as knight e5 check that precipitated
with kg7 and believe knight takes
d5 is now
what we're about to see and that will be
followed by e3 e4 and
well
it's grim
and it's grim
yeah by my count this will be 12 and the
scores will be level 66 but i i did it
very briefly now just clicking through
the rounds but maybe i'm wrong
uh yeah black definitely holding uh
holding their own
in this event
remarkable uh trying to remember when
black has scored this well this is
i think we've had a recent tournament
where
i can't yeah i think one of the vikes
maybe black was doing quite well
remember i covered the tournament where
black scored way above what you would
normally expect in a in a top field but
right
can't remember exactly what it was
all right and let me just see what has
happened after the move b five
[Music]
yeah there's some shuffling going on but
with the rooks without the g-file and
the queen on e65 before squares
just doesn't seem like white has any
initiative and the knight on d3 is about
to get supported by the sea pawn and the
rook only two will never make a move
again in this game it's just grim
totally yeah
it's getting worse and worse as black
seems to be suffocating white's pieces
ever more
i almost felt like
look at this
look at this move
rookie one that's almost like
you know like
um i almost want to play queen f5
against it because i can't i wanted to
go queen c4 but queen b1 still exists
and annoyingly i thought queen c4 was
just winning on the spot but it's kind
of amazing this move doesn't lose in
this match yeah queen b1 still kind of
keeps the game afloat somehow but i mean
it's it's very and rookie one was only
played because yasser said that this
rook would never i i said it i said
i said it
but it's on me
yes of course it is i i i just
i i don't know if uh jan has a sense of
humor at such moments i suspect not that
it's extremely dark but he has a sense
of humor
like he is a very very
like a genuinely funny guy but uh
much of it is aimed at himself right and
is darker than
than most people would like you know to
aim with themselves we're blind queen g6
just
you
okay
sends the game just ends the game yeah
you want to do anyone against anything
like rook e2 and knight e1
yeah yeah yeah queen g6 is just like
it's really significant queen is just
yeah forces an immediate resignation
yeah
just put him out of his misery there
also i don't know queen of five king can
go somewhere yeah that's different yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah when the five would have been
nice but king king can go to g1 in the
game that was the visual that you liked
the alejandra it was just pretty that
was yeah right there's no need for it
queen g6 is just game over yeah shaq
should spot this pretty much instantly
normally yeah normally but i mean the
only way you don't play which sticks
here is simply because they remove
pretty much wins so you don't need to
but right yeah but your spider spidey
senses like
yeah yeah yeah i'm pretty active right
here yeah and this uh again uh nicely
setting up a discover check
uh the knight currently in a pin you
can't take the rook but you block the
pin oops excuse me you blocked the pin
with the move queen g6 and then you set
up a discover check either this way or
this way this way is pretty nice
yeah
no this is this is g6
we we're not really
used to seeing this as much anymore from
jan even though he he did have some
blow-ups in in the world championship
much but in general he is
this is kind of a game he would play i
don't know three years ago five years
ago when he is not informed and kind of
annoyed with himself
but he's cut it out largely out of his
system like it's it's no longer you know
very streaky players yeah a thing that
happens to him uh as often but yeah this
is just not good
but it in in some ways i think both and
he's shaking his head as he's
as he's now spotted queen g6 and i think
that's
a tell that shaq
is picking up on as well by the way i
think shaw is sporting this uh adidas
look today which i every time the
sportive look yeah i see this and i
think i'm
nice
um
i think of shaq is also a very streaky
player is that
fair i mean when things are going well
they are really really going well and
when things are going poorly well
we're going poorly yeah but this will
this will cheer him up no questions
oh my gosh oh my god yeah queen c4
they're the first every move wins so
we're not going to be critical about it
right too critical yeah yeah i mean but
queen c4 as the kind of the first
impression i guess queen be one queen
before and just get the queens off and
this is also just completely and utterly
winning hard to criticize once yeah
right i mean because you've got a three
versus one majority i mean you only need
one win right yeah right if you find it
clean enough win and it's without the
queens yeah just get the queens off
the knight
[Music]
we've got the intermezzo check
so we have to move our queen and we're
expecting queen bee yeah that's the only
move that doesn't lose the the rook and
i i suspect it's been played with the
idea of queen before queen takes before
is strictly the only move here
i'm guessing c takes before also wins
but why do that take with the knight
rookie to check 93 knight h2 whatever
whatever you want to follow it up
on the board
it prolongs the game but i mean the
result remains largely not in doubt as
victor corchine i would say it's the
abcs of chess yeah let's let's put it
this way if queen g6 didn't exist queen
c4 will be praising yeah yeah it's a
good good practical solution and we do
have queen b1 on the board in response
by the way it is a little surprising for
me um to see top grandmaster like shaq
making the move and keeping his hand
on the piece for an extended period of
time and by an extended period of time i
mean anything beyond two three seconds
but sometimes as long as 10 20 30
seconds
um
i always thought it was bad form what
about yourselves a little bit
i don't know i i never felt it was
necessarily bad form i think it's a sign
of him not being entirely certain like
he even in the position as winning as
this and he knows he is winning by this
of course of course uh
it feels like you know the the way the
tournament has been going up to this
point is influencing his like he's
double and triple checking things yeah
everybody blitz out without like a
second thought
i think it just sort of gives away gives
the way the game a little bit in terms
of like how confident he is right now
about his decision making because yeah
normally a lack of confidence yeah yeah
exactly
because normally you wouldn't really be
you know doubting yourself to
to such a degree yeah and uh we do have
the queen trade as you were mentioned
the queen's come off and the arkham one
is an important move here to at least
try to activate something you know get
rook f7 or c7 or something it's a good
move it's probably the only way to
keep the game somewhat afloat but yeah
you just feel that the c pawn is really
yeah you get rook c6 in the end there in
the line i was talking about like c4 and
he has reached for it and there you go
and again i i think this is like shaq
just
having a bad event to begin with and
you're seeing that he's not
confident about his play so he just
is making these moves with this
kind of please god
i'm not blundering
it doesn't really create enough of
of anything really yes exactly knight
takes a2 c3 c2
is just going uh
also
knight d3
and then get the knights off if you need
in in winner rook ending i think there's
a number of ways of winning this
like c3 e5 rook c6
as long as as long as we're not
blundering something there and i don't
think we are yeah king h8 i don't i
don't see any particular problems with
it just get it to c2 so that the rook
kind of you know has to forget about
ever venturing outside exactly so
one thing that white has on his agenda
as rook f7 rook c7 you put your rook on
c6 yeah but we always have
response yeah
and is this one winds down our look
ahead
for the remaining schedule very
straightforward we have two more rounds
to go after this one uh friday the 13th
uh tomorrow
spooky
spooky
and we will have a few days between
these tournaments and we come back with
a rapid and blitz a lot of these players
will be traveling to warsaw poland will
be joined by a great cast a lot of
talent especially young talent being
brought up in that tournament as you see
the players list there i'm particularly
excited to see uh shivchenko
one of those young players we've been
hearing about for a few years now coming
up and you finally want to put them up
there see how how they test against the
best of the best
youth is unsound give me vishy
that will be our second stop of the uh
grand chess tour with three more to go
and we do have yeah
yeah i mean the calculations here you do
have to be a bit careful about allowing
rook f7 or c7 but the calculations don't
really look that difficult like if i go
rook c6 because it's a white is never in
time to establish the
like the the setup you want is the rook
on d7 and then the perpetual on the f6
h7 squares but by this point the pawn
will be on c2 and we will just snap on
cc so like like what if there's a gold
rook is six yeah yeah i understand i
understand so just to
show uh what
white's
potential dream even this is just
completely lost right because
the rook is not on the right square so
we just run towards d8 this is not a
perpetual
that's quite cute
this is quite cool
the rook c6 played no we actually have
to try to like not win this for what i
did find a way
to check
f7 and e6 and that one actually didn't
manage to win with with with the black
music yeah
rook c6 is the right is the very very
clean idea here yeah rooks belong behind
past pawns and by the way i
mean why did several of them be short
here not just one
i mean your cruel idea of like forcing
the trade of knights that would have
been
really kind of brutal too because that
just
stops any kind of counter play with your
rook on c6
uh
definitely picking the bones on this one
let's uh turn back to the uh there is a
kind of failing to make progress so
everything is still on the board like
you would have expected
a pawn to fall somewhere uh definitely
in fact
right here
and he did not take the pawn
yeah i can because
it's
the rooks come off rook h5 exists and he
does not want to allow
uh the rook trade because this is this
is how on a rare occasion that you don't
win this position this is how it starts
a pair of rogues comes off and then the
rook is
legitimately rook is much stronger than
tonight's on a completely like i go
through k7 here and i start
creating some counter play i want to
play rook a3 c3 c2 there's also an
outside passer on the age file to
distract you when you start controlling
i'm assuming this is winning for white
but
but you would like and this is kind of
like
this is a kind of a trap that you fall
into when you're converting positions
like this because your position in
general is so harmonious and so safe
that you would like to win without
having to calculate a single variation
exactly this is the dream the dream is
of never allowing any account to play
whatsoever and the lazy grand master
dream i like that i like the lazy grapes
kind of a maxim that uh was you know
quote unquote taught to me uh early is
that
you have to prepare yourself mentally if
you're playing as a strong player
obviously like if this is a simul game
against against an amateur this may not
be true but against a strong player you
absolutely have to steal yourself
for the fact that
there will always be at least one spot
where your opponent will force you to
calculate
there'll be a moment yeah and jan does
resign now
yeah he's going to be a very unhappy
camper no question about it just a very
where we left it rook c6 rook czech king
g8 rook d7 c2 e6000
uh he despite the move e6 uh hoping
against hope that his opponent would
fall for a terrible trap
and allow a mate in one uh two pardon me
uh
he didn't not not much surprisingly six
and then rook c7 rook c6 and yeah it's
it's a full queen on on c2 there just
it's a girl it's an actual it's an
actual full queen yeah yeah and that's
the end and like you say this is not
going to be a nice interview
no and for shaq
wow
and his play was just not
poor and now suddenly
you know it's a sort of like okay yeah
he's finally won a game and he's back on
minus one not not in dead last and right
uh it's a it's a much better feeling and
for him i mean he will be annoyed i mean
despite winning he will be annoyed by by
age six exactly and realizing he was
lost he he just as all top professionals
he will be extremely unhappy about the
fact that he blundered you know the
entire like the entire game was
blundered in one move
but you know the
the relief of knowing it didn't happen
the relief of knowing you got amnesty
there right we'll you know lessen the
pain right uh for for sure clemency was
uh yeah was allowed rook a5 as you say
uh alejandro the lazy man's way but
guess what that looks very effective
that's very effective it doesn't look
good you are dropping d5 of that i mean
then even if you go to k7 yeah yes i got
rook c5 that's
i take take 96.
yeah that is good yeah that would be
that would be a way to
resign
or knight e6 yeah
don't trade rooks but definitely rook c5
made stopping uh any chances rook season
and preparing knight
takes d5
winning yep
yeah actually ali rosa is managing to do
the cgm way not trading no but he
actually has calculated i mean he's
refused to take a couple of upon a
couple of occasions because he correctly
estimates that with the rooks on the
conversion will be significantly
significantly easier it's the right way
to go about things
if you can keep the rooks on the board
in these types of positions it's very
very beneficial to you i remember
afghani barriers he did an annotation
for new inches
magazine where he had like one of these
silky
smooth victories
where he didn't analyze
or calculate any variation he just put
all of his pieces in the nicest squares
and just took things
and he said a perfect game
i didn't analyze anything it was great
and uh they made a strong impression on
me
we should those are those are the ones
you enjoy the good thing
it feels like you you've won through the
superior chess understanding you haven't
really you
not tricks not not any of those you know
precisely cheapos but yeah
you understood the game but i just had
to point out one thing by the way uh
night shack
with the idea that if you play king here
uh
and i get this it doesn't actually win
in exchange because after
king g8 knight c7 there is rook b to
check also the king of six i guess you
don't have to put it on g8
oh i'm sorry at the same point yes yeah
king james actually loses the exchange
to rookie
and then again and then
then a fork after all okay
so he did play rook a5 uk5 is very clean
yeah and uh sorry we're waiting for uh
blacks
but let's jump to bucharest with a very
happy
shack we are
check
thank you yasir a very happy and
relieved shakuriyama medyarov after his
first victory shaq first of all uh tell
us your first feelings after this
important victory okay it was not easy
game i think after the openings looks
very good position for me i think it's
okay i will
win in
in middle game
but after i start to play very very bad
i don't know i i remember is my last
year game from uh
against the shanghai when i got a very
good position 5 16
and he missed something and after i
think okay i will win for sure but i
lose this game after
i think my turn is going not very well
and this today is all the same i think
it's okay it looks very good this will
winning position in without pawn but
after i start to sing sing sing but
after i don't understand where is
winning position is it just a
strategical
you mentioned something uh
when you first came to the studio you
mentioned that after you saw
the
rookie five of richie report you just
couldn't play anymore or you felt bad
tell us a bit about that yeah i know it
is very bad for
super grand masters i i my feeling of
course is
very bad when i see some just players
mismove like this i also miss sometimes
uh
like this
it's very bad and i see his research
i never see it like this i mean when he
see he play and he says we miss
so you're worried about the image
i was near him i see you know how his
vehicle and his
that's not easy i mean it's not very
good and before the candidates of course
is because there's a two two big miss
for this chart here is
against baghdad and
today
uh it's really bad but i hope
he'll look back and he will show he will
remember who is legend absolutely now
let's go through the game and you were
mentioning you felt you were in pole
position after the opening tell us
exactly the moment where it goes g3 it
was a surprise for me i think it's 98
bishop d5 after 98 normally play
everyone but my g3 i think is okay i
need to play same f5
uh and here d4 okay i think
i don't understand first i mean okay
i play first time this
position but the d4
is okay i know this
normal to sacrifice for activity but i
don't understand
before because g5 is also okay but i
think take take
because g5 is bishop's d2
because bishop d2 and it's very good the
bishop comes up yeah yeah yeah
but
bishop f4 but i think take now not take
quincy tribution before
and now i think
younger again in rook d once he will
sacrifice one more phone
it will be very nice very good i hope he
will play rook to one son because he
don't like this position g5 is very big
adventure
yeah i mean first i think g4 is winning
a very good g4 i think he missed because
take now i can take e3 and now it's
absolutely different now you have ninety
five five diagonalized g4 yeah but g4
after uh g4 uh
g4 queen f4
here queen f4 is very strong
is only only move g4 point four and uh
okay uh and i think okay i have just one
pawn extra and no attack uh i
look this constructions i mean
it looks great for you i mean it's very
strange no pawn and very bad pawn
structures close to winning and yeah it
looks like we're close to winning i
think it's okay i need to play some good
moves and i will win but perhaps the
king is a little bit weak yeah but one
extra opponent's very red pawns for
white and you do have full control over
the longest it looks very bad but i
think okay but okay
queen h5 queen need to be g6 and only
now i when i played all normal moves i
understand is not very easy because in
when i play 95 i think this move is
winning
and i absolutely miss
bishop c2
queen e6
he take
f4 take g4 and the queen foreign
again
uh absolutely normal position now and so
now you have to regroup and try to find
a different plan yeah and now the
problem is once bishop c2 comes you have
some difficulty i understand is not very
good so not aware of opposition i mean i
understand just equal it looks but i
again instantly only black can play for
win here i mean not white but uh would
you say you were a bit frustrated uh i
think
of course i don't want to play e6 well
how is possible to play a6 when you need
to play some uh
but therefore bishop c2 quincy yeah
okay
when you have so many options and queen
g8 is the only one
yeah g8 uh okay i play i think rook have
seven look at 60s looks
normal
yeah very natural yeah
look at in 97
and just to stop it for a second because
we do have a result we have ferruja who
just beat lanier dominguez and won his
first game just like you in the
tournament so two first game wins for um
okay i think still my position is better
here but it's very strange because uh
when i miss i want to play luke c6 yeah
it's it was which
i missed c4 movie i mean it's when i
this c4 i miss
of course if not c4 black is better but
i miss c4
discuss yeah yeah
about queen d2 because uh i don't like
this move uh
i know we get some sort of a similar
thing yeah bishop takes f5 and well the
problem is if you take rotates f5 you're
actually queen to d8 is coming you
cannot exchange yeah yeah but i i i
think maybe it's possible to play some
yeah
yeah but it's just normal
yeah i don't know i i played in this
tournament very strange also i all games
i think i am better i don't know why my
position every time i think is very good
position but it is very strange because
also here i i
i want to play this move i miss
i want to play queen b6 and bishop bc
bishop is six yeah he's made yeah he's
made immediately i mean it's very easy
to miss and also is a take take take
take take it's amazing is if play if you
only move because if queen d6 is quindy
to the amazing i mean yes it is winning
yeah and we were looking at it right now
from outside and we couldn't find the
defense for you did you once i see this
calculator hold this one yeah look see
one i think so now is my position is
okay because king h2 in this 60 again is
queen b turks c5
king f2 is same but i'm very lucky
because it's king gift
26 queen b2 and then this moment came
yeah i mean here i was very happy
because it's this move again queen edge
to check eyes
yeah i mean it looks silly i mean i'm
very happy because it's not this shake
is losing position i mean there's no
other chance no no i mean looks it would
take after queenish so that's ideal
queen h2 yeah it was i was really lucky
because
okay now i pick 26 now okay
position is normal
kg2
did you uh did you spot this queen to f2
at this point yeah of course you did
yeah i think it's in i can't play
97. rotate c5
is
queen
yeah his problem is like calculate
knight c5 perhaps you miss queen bee too
because now the queen gets back on the
other side
okay it was that not yeah i mean
sometime
problems oh come on
and okay it's very good for my chess
career to say no i will back my mood
look back because sometimes luck is very
important very very important no come on
this is my person okay it's very very
strange did you guys uh spot this moment
with numbers
no because okay you say somebody's
winning i see you
it looks very dangerous for me but uh i
miss the night it can be too many so
perhaps a mutual blind spot yeah it's
because i think knight c5 queen f7 queen
d2 is draw
that's just yeah i'm pointing around
either take take when you're seven and
it's draw just row yes yeah but it
couldn't be killing this yeah now the
queen goes back
come on checkmate come on it's okay i
mean
after after again something he played
rook to f6 yeah here queen d3 i want to
play with the amazing normal queen d3
but this move
very strange i mean how is possible move
like queen d4 i don't know that's okay i
i think queen d1
still is okay now at this point after
rook f6 this sequence of moves uh did
you consider yourself to be better in
the position were you the one playing
for a victory
looks very strange because after 25 king
king g3 i calculate king g3
also i was afraid this move king g3 is
not easy to play okay queen d6 is rook
f6 93 and game uh is look straw yeah i
mean take take knight b2
yeah i just calculate this draw yeah
it's i think it's because it was only to
move to play before the before the timer
yeah he played this movie six king ji
knight g3 yeah and he missed
rp5 i mean it's not like big miss but he
was not very happy because he
understandably he missed something and
now he starts to play very well because
after the time control he understands he
miss
big chance to win and it also doesn't
feel like he has an easy draw anymore
yeah and now is not easy draw now is
a certainly interesting position group
queen c2 rook d5 is rook d2 idea every
time and
of course king is very strange but now i
think the again black is better this
position
looks very good for black
queen e4
[Music]
but not human queen
d2
why is good
just take
perhaps uh yeah block d2 is yeah well
we missed this queen if i think he also
missed and the king g2
and the rook d3 is a very good move
because now
my rook is close everything and maybe
some attacks nice very bad position
he played you played knight to d3 at
this point know i don't play rook d3 no
not yeah i think i played
but still you're maintaining the
advantage and after that it went all the
way up to this point
which you finished handling is just a
little bit off the middle game he played
very bad shaq first victory thanks uh
definitely a boost of confidence going
into the final two rounds what's going
to be your strategy okay for last round
first rule i'm very happy to finally
it's a
big luck because it's not really big
luck because also i don't understand my
position is losing yeah when you don't
understand you're sitting like is you're
winning you
but for europe it's also not easy uh we
both think is normal position but we
miss one move uh that's okay is the one
it is one
more than one point for me it is because
now is my mood will good for next
tournaments for uh i mean also for next
games okay shaq congratulations and
we'll see you in the next couple of days
thank you very guys back to you thank
you christian
i have to say we
really really enjoy your interview if
this doesn't become a comedy show this
is great
if this doesn't become a gif in the next
i don't know half an hour though
something is wrong with it it's
brilliant yeah
oh come on moment
needs to become viral
i like this he's six i know like i don't
play
my personal favorite is like yes rook d3
is very strong
it was fantastic
but here's how our day has finished up
all the games
alireza finally winning a game chakri
are finally winning a game and reheard
after that horrible horrible one-move
blunder is now back to uh dead last and
minus two
uh yeah
and and yan dropping uh dropping into
into the minor zone as well which is you
know he was on plus one and playing well
he won this very very impressive game
with the black pieces against the gereza
but now yeah he's not going to be
enjoying tonight exactly once once he
gets stalled by either his seconds or
the engine or whatever what happened ali
reza our pre-tournament favorite by
raiding uh wins his first game uh brings
a
striking distance and he is with
christian in bucharest
thank you yasir first of all alireza
congratulations a big victory for your
first victory of the tournament back to
50
what are your initial feelings right now
yes i'm very happy of course and it was
a very difficult game
linear knew the opening very well but
after in time trouble it was anything
could have happened but
this time finally it went my way and you
started off with this very popular uh
line of at the nimzo take us a bit
through the opening phase
yeah this is very popular right now
wesley played against charlier in round
one i think
it's the
best way to get the game at least but
it's very very risky i think double
action very double yes
and you guys got to this position where
you just continue throwing your pawns in
direction of your opponent was this
still preparation
until here okay after a tc4 g6
virtual f8 h4 h6 rd1 until here i knew
the moves and then i know some plans
here but it's very it's very
sharp so black could win what could be
anything could happen um b5 is a great
move here
just to
not waste time and start attacking
create your own counter play on the
queen side that's black yeah i have i
had this e4 option
but i couldn't
make it work after knight h7
um because he will go to end game right
take three sticks
things are being simplified yeah and
then it's nothing here yeah you wanted
to play for uh for a win-win you didn't
want to achieve any business today yes
so you decided to
keep some pieces on the board right now
i want e4
so queen d7 queen g2 bishop design here
it was very critical
position i couldn't find the right plan
i think
um
yeah h4 is logical
to go g5 and
kick the knight
but i give a lot of weaknesses in
on king sites yeah
what were your main concerns in these
positions intelligence of peace
placement in terms of your opponent
building up on attack what were you
mostly answering about yeah i have two
moves left i have to create something
otherwise i just
get crushed here right
so
oh yeah it's very
it's very concrete position anyway so h4
97 yeah here he's better i think a5
actually is better because to keep the
queen in center right and it does seem
like this is in fact
the other roof yes yes
the best move in the position according
to the engine yes but still yet g5 king
f2 is still very sharp very complicated
position
and here i had to go for this
and it felt like this was the critical
moment that changed the title of the
game after rook to each one he played
this move knight to f5 and this allows
you one extra move you played into h3
nicely spotting the fact that that
knight to h5 yeah he blundered of course
knight h5 otherwise he would not play
but still i think this position
is very different
here
it's very difficult for banach
because two or three moves i get made so
and here it's not clear what is his plan
exactly so
yeah now engine says black should play
f5 at some point which is
very difficult
so
yeah here queen exchange here also it's
very difficult for me to to find the
plan
uh because were you surprised that he
played this backwards move after playing
knight to f5 and thinking for two-thirds
of his yeah yeah he doesn't have any
other move yeah it's mate otherwise
so i was not surprised because it's made
otherwise uh pedor was actually calling
this moment one of the most difficult
moments in just going making a move and
then having to retreat immediately after
accept the mistake yes it's very
difficult
here also it's very difficult for me
here i have to find something
very fast so
i played knight g3 which is
it's okay i think but uh yeah okay six
to defend here i took
i couldn't see anything better than
bishop before so thanks greg they seemed
all according to plan exchange and here
i have to be solid 38 queen g4 goes back
queen takes coming forward now knight to
c6
no here it's very difficult to spot this
for g7
did you see h7 in the india once you
played queen to f4 right now i've seen
this seven until when i took him before
these ideas of rokusan
but yeah he blundered this
but i think i thought queen v8 maybe but
this end game i think i am still pushing
for slightly better yes
perhaps you get this nice c3 and here is
very unpleasant for black
so you were still confident at this
point and after knight to c6
yeah you spotted immediately
were you surprised that he actually
found the only move to stay in the game
now he found the fantastic idea yeah
with one second
yes but i i wanted to play rook h1 first
which is the most logical because queen
h4 is not very logical but yeah here
it's not a very good version i think
yeah
very good spot yes yeah
so rookie six queen h4 yeah he has to
take
many lines queen defense h8 it's amazing
but yeah this end game is winning
missing
technically
so yeah and here okay slowly
and you managed to win alireza you're
back to 50 one point behind the leaders
going into the final two rounds are you
still dreaming about winning this
tournament and if you ask what is your
strategy to win it a winning is very
difficult i have basically tomorrow
black
so he's very solid player but we will
see
um i am trying to play my very good
chess but
i got many winning positions but
unfortunately i couldn't make it work
but yeah hopefully in the last two games
we could
play better and we will see of course
after five months of inactivity is
difficult to get back into it but this
win do you feel the confidence rising
once again yes some confidence is going
back
it was long it's long term it didn't win
so
yeah it's good to win the game
excellent arizona thank you
congratulations once again and we'll see
you in the next few rounds
guys back to you thank you christians
our congratulations to ali raisa if we
have the championship rounds that's what
i like to call them coming up we see the
pairings for rounds eight as well as
rounds nine but tomorrow yeah the
critical pairings are what stands out
yeah
wesley wesley and levon are leading the
tournament so wesley is white against
the result there is clearly i mean he's
been he was a bit cagey about it but i
think he will try i think he will work
it's difficult against wesley because
wesley obviously will have a say in it
but right i think alirezaville will will
try to give him a bite and and to get a
double h position
he's on the outside yeah yeah and then
his white against bogdan who you know
he's been playing very very well but
still it's it's a chance for for mvl to
perhaps uh fully catch up to our two
leaders
as usual plenty plenty to look forward
to every round is is great and our
championship round is coming up in round
nine peter yeah levon is white against
shahriar who will feel slightly better
after today despite all the
all the excitement of that interview
yeah
i'm telling you he's going to do his own
comedy show i mean he is brilliant he is
fantastic yeah
playing his countrymen uh
they're potentially a very very
important game and wesley is black
against lanier where
i mean uh they've clearly played
they've
played a ton against each other yes they
know each other very very well uh nice
pairings uh coming up and what about our
predictions no no no the graphic is uh
the graphic was lost the predictions the
predictions oh no
no look at this
oh
richie nice one alejandro
i must say i'm not crowing out very
loudly uh myself you guys have uh
farouza you were somewhat off
somewhat caught up i mean
there is
literally the leader so far
various murky he's happy he's happy with
this pic right right and uh nice
shall we go to bucharest for some final
thoughts about this very lesson
round seven christian anastasia over to
you
well uh what a day this was guys uh a
lot of stories are happening in this
tournament but one that i'm having my
eyes on of course is richie rapport not
finding himself going into the
candidates as well as ali reza who's
getting his first victory and i feel it
he's getting his confidence back going
into the final two games while this guy
is going to be very very difficult to
stop so i'm looking forward to see what
he's going to be bringing to the table
for the last championship rounds as you
guys were calling them anastasia how
about yourself yeah of course it's been
a really interesting day and there was
something in the air today you know i
felt this tension this pressure and
we have the new winners we have uh
finally shah who scored his first point
and also alireza as you mentioned and of
course i was expecting a lot from the
game between richie and danville but of
course i didn't know that it will finish
this way and
fans of richard of course aren't happy
at this moment i just cannot imagine
what will happen tomorrow that we have
fridays or teens
so i'm just even afraid to think about
it it's been a good day for us in our
predictions and we're definitely looking
forward to the last two rounds guys back
to you in the studio we'll see you
tomorrow
thank you both absolutely we will see
you tomorrow
do join us and thank you very much for
sharing today
but alejandro your last and final
thoughts about this these adventures of
today the prequel of the friday 13th
how is the prequel was the actual movie
going to look like this was enough
blunders for one tournament let alone
one round i think that we're gonna see
better chess tomorrow we're gonna see
exciting fights but less blunders
i hope so
hard to imagine more you're here
all right with that uh we'll say our
final good night and wish you all a very
happy day see you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited